welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Dr Sam Harris Dr Sam Harris did
his undergraduate training in philosophy
at Stanford University and then went on
to do his Doctorate in neuroscience at
the University of California at Los
Angeles
he is well known as an author who has
written about everything from meditation
to Consciousness Free Will and he holds
many strong political views that he's
voiced on social media and in the
content of various books as they relate
to philosophy and Neuroscience during
today's episode I mainly talked to Dr
Harris about his views and practices
related to meditation Consciousness and
Free Will in fact he made several
important points about what a proper
meditation practice can accomplish prior
to this episode I thought that
meditation was about deliberately
changing one's conscious experience in
order to achieve things such as deeper
relaxation a heightened sense of focus
or ability to focus generally elevated
memory and so on what Sam taught me and
what you'll soon learn as well is that
while meditation does indeed hold all of
those valuable benefits the main value
of a meditation practice or perhaps the
greater value of a meditation practice
is that it doesn't just allow one to
change their conscious experience but it
actually can allow a human being to view
Consciousness itself that is to
understand what the process of
Consciousness is and in doing so to
profoundly shift the way that one
engages with the world and with oneself
in all practices all environments and at
all times both in sleep and in waking
States and in that way making meditation
perhaps the most potent and important
portal by which one can access novel
ways of thinking and being and viewing
one's life experience we also discussed
the so-called mind-body problem and
issues of Duality and Free Will Concepts
from philosophy and Neuroscience that
fortunately thanks to valuable
experiments and deep thinking on the
part of people like Dr Sam Harris and
others is now leading people to
understand really what free will is and
isn't where the locus of free will
likely sits in the brain if it indeed
resides in the brain at all and what it
means to be a conscious being and how we
can can modify our conscious States in
ways that allow us to be more functional
we also discuss perception both visual
perception auditory perception and
especially interesting to me and I think
as well hopefully to you time perception
which we know is very elastic in the
brain
the literal frame rate by which we
process our conscious experience can
expand and contract dramatically
depending on our state of mind and how
conscious we are about our state of mind
so we went deep into that topic as well
today's discussion was indeed an
intellectual Deep dive into all the
topics that I mentioned a few moments
ago but it also included many practical
Tools in fact I pushed Sam to share with
us what his specific practices are and
how we can all arrive at a clear and
better understanding of a meditation
practice that we can each and all apply
so that we can derive these incredible
benefits not just the ones related to
stress and focus and enhanced memory but
the ones that relate to our
Consciousness that is to our deeper
sense of self and to others several
times during today's episode I mentioned
the waking up app The Waking Up app was
developed by Sam Harris but I want to
emphasize that my mention of the app is
in no way a paid promotional rather The
Waking Up app is one that I've used for
some period of time now and find very
very useful I have family members that
also use it other staff members here at
The huberman Lab podcast use it because
we find it to be such a powerful tool
Sam has generously offered huberman Lab
podcast listeners a 30-day completely
free trial of the waking up app if any
of you want to try it you can simply go
to wakingup.com huberman to get that 30
day free trial during today's discussion
we didn't just talk about meditation
Consciousness and Free Will we also
talked about psychedelics both their
therapeutic applications for the
treatment of things like depression and
PTSD
but also the use of psychedelics and we
discuss Sam's experiences with
psychedelics as they relate to expanding
one's Consciousness I also asked Sam
about his views and practices related to
social media prompted in no small part
by his recent voluntary decision to
close down his Twitter account so we
talked about his rationale for doing
that how he feels about doing that and I
think you'll find that to be very
interesting as well before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public I'm keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is levels
levels is a program that lets you see
how different foods and behaviors affect
your health by giving you real-time
feedback using a continuous glucose
monitor one of the most important
factors in your immediate and long-term
Health are your blood sugar levels and
not just your overall blood sugar levels
but your blood sugar levels throughout
the day in response to different foods
you eat to fasting if you're into
fasting to exercise and so forth I
started using levels some time ago in
order to figure out how different foods
impact my blood sugar levels and indeed
it does that very well it allowed me to
see how certain foods really Spike my
blood sugar and others keep it more
level
and in particular how foods that I eat
after exercise can help raise my blood
glucose just enough but not so much that
then I get a crash two or three hours
later which is what was happening before
I started using levels I've made certain
adjustments to my diet I can now eat
post exercise and still have plenty of
energy throughout the day without any
issue it also has helped me understand
how different behaviors impact my blood
glucose levels if you're interested in
learning more about levels and trying a
continuous glucose monitor yourself go
to levels.link huberman again that's
levels dot link spelled l-i-n-k slash
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by whoop whoop is a fitness
wearable device that tracks your daily
activity and sleep but goes beyond
activity and sleep tracking to provide
real-time feedback on how to adjust your
training and sleep schedules in order to
feel and perform better six months ago I
started working with whoop as a member
of their scientific advisory Council as
a way to help whoop Advance their
mission of unlocking Human Performance
and as a whoop user I've experienced
firsthand the health benefits of their
technology apology it's clear based on
quality research that woop can inform
you how well you're sleeping how to
change your sleep habits how to change
your activity habits even how to modify
different aspects of your nutrition
exercise sleep and lifestyle in order to
maximize your mental health physical
health and performance so whether or not
you're an athlete or you're exercising
simply for health whoop can really help
you understand how your body functions
under different conditions and how to
really program your schedule nutrition
and exercise and many other factors of
your life in order to really optimize
your health and performance including
your cognition if you're interested in
trying whoop you can go to join whoop
spelled
w-h-o-oop.com huberman that's
joinwoop.com huberman today and get your
first month free today's episode is also
brought To Us by eight sleep eight sleep
makes Smart mattress covers with cooling
Heating and sleep tracking capacity I've
talked many times before on this podcast
about the fact that sleep is the
fundamental layer of mental health
physical health and performance now one
of the key things for getting a great
night's sleep every single night is to
optimize the temperature of your
sleeping environment put simply in order
to fall asleep and stay deeply asleep
your body temperature needs to drop by
about one to three degrees and waking up
on the other hand involves a heating of
your body by about one to three degrees
with AIDS sleep you can tune the
temperature of your mattress cover or
mattress to be cooler or hotter
depending on whether or not you tend to
run too hot or too cold and you can even
vary it across the night so that you can
access the best deep sleep early in the
night the so-called REM sleep rapid eye
movement sleep that's more pronounced in
the later half of the night and doing so
really get your sleep optimized not just
in terms of duration but in terms of
quality and the overall architecture of
your sleep this has a profound influence
on your alertness focused mood and many
other important factors throughout the
day if you'd like to try eight sleep you
can go to eightsleep.com huberman to
save up to 150 off their pod 3 cover
eight sleep currently ships to the USA
Canada United Kingdom select countries
in the EU and Australia again that's
eightsleep.com slash huberman the
huberman Lab podcast is proud to
announce that we are now partnered with
momentous supplements because momentous
supplements are of the very highest
quality they ship internationally and
they have single ingredient formulations
if you'd like to access the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so livemomentis.com huberman and now for
my discussion with Dr Sam Harris Dr Sam
Harris
we're just talking about this you're
indeed a doctor I cannot save your life
but uh I am I might I might save your
non-existent soul if we talk long enough
well neither of us are clinicians but we
are both
brain explorers from the different
perspectives some overlapping yeah and
I'm really excited to have this
conversation I've been listening to your
voice for many years learning from you
for many years and I'd be remiss if I
didn't say that my father who's also a
scientist is an enormous fan of your
waking up app nice and has spent a lot
of time over the last few years he's in
his late 70s he's almost 80. it's a
theoretical physicist walking to the
park near his apartment and spending
time meditating with the app or
sometimes separate from the app but
using the same sorts of meditations in
his head yeah so he kind of toggles back
and forth and even uh I shouldn't say
even but yes even in his late 70s has
reported that it is significantly
shifted his awareness of self and his
conscious experience of things happening
in and around him and he was somebody
who I think
already saw himself as uh pretty aware
person thinking about you know quantum
mechanics and and the rest so a thank
you from him indirectly I thank you from
me uh now directly and I really want to
use that as a way to frame up what I
think is one of the more interesting
questions and
not just science and philosophy and
psychology but all of life which is
what is this thing that we call a self
you know as far as I know we have not
localized the region in the brain that
can entirely account for our perception
of self their areas of course that
regulate proprioception you know our
awareness of where our limbs are in
space maybe even our awareness of where
we are in physical space there are such
circuits as we both know yeah but when
we talk about sense of self
I have to remember this kind of
Neuroscience 101 thing that we always
say you know when you teach memory you
say you know you wake up every morning
and you remember who you are you know
who you are most people do even if they
lack memory systems in the brain for
whatever reason
pretty much everyone seems to know who
they are what are your thoughts on what
that whole thing is about and do we come
into the world feeling that way I would
appreciate answers from the perspective
of any field in the Neuroscience of
course yeah well big question I mean the
problem is we we use the term self in so
many different ways right and and
there's there's one sense
of that term which is the target of
meditation and it's the target of
deconstruction by the practice and by
interesting any surrounding philosophy
so you'll hear and you'll hear it from
me that
this self is an illusion right and and
that there's a there's a psychological
Freedom that can be experienced on the
other side of discovering it to be an
illusion
um and some people don't like that
framing some people would would insist
that it's not so much an illusion but
it's a construct and it's not what it
seems right
um
but it's not that every use of the term
self is illegitimate and there are
certain types of selves that are not
illusory I mean you know I'm not saying
that people are Illusions I'm not saying
that you can't
um
uh talk about yourself as distinct
yourself as the whole person and and you
know with as you know psychological
continuity with your past experience uh
as being distinct from the person and
psychological continuity of some other
person right obviously we have to be
able to conserve those data it's not
fundamentally mysterious that you're
going to wake up tomorrow morning still
being psychologically continuous with
your past and not my past right and and
you know if we swapped lives you know
that would you know demand some
explanation
um so the illusoriness of the self
doesn't
cut against any of those obvious facts
so the the the the sense of self that is
illusory and again we might want to talk
about self in other modes because
there's there's just a lot of interest
there psychologically and you know
ultimately uh scientifically
um
the thing that doesn't exist uh
certainly doesn't exist as it seems and
I would I would want to argue that it
actually is just a proper illusion uh
is this the sense that there is a
subject interior to experience in
addition to experience so most people
feel like they're having an experience
of the world and they're having their an
experience of their bodies in the world
and in addition to that they feel that
they are a subject internal to the body
you know very likely in the head most
people feel like they're behind their
face as a kind of locus of awareness and
thought and intention and and
that every it's almost like they're
you're a passenger inside your body you
don't most people don't feel identical
to their bodies and they can imagine
this this is
so the origin the psychological origin
and you know the folk psychological
origin of a sense of that there's there
might be a soul that could survive the
death of the body I mean most people are
are what my friend Paul Bloom calls
common sense dualists right you you
you're just the default
expectation seems to be that whatever
the relationship between the mind and
the body
there is this there's some promise of
separability there right that the and
whenever you you really push hard on the
science side and say well no no the mind
is really just what the brain is doing
that begins to feel more and more
counterintuitive to people and there
still seems some some residual mystery
that you know at death maybe something
is going to lift off the brain and go
elsewhere right so there's a sense of
dualism uh that many people have and
obviously that that's supported by Many
religious beliefs
um
but this feeling it is a very peculiar
starting point the the people feel that
in it you know they don't feel identical
to their experience right it's a matter
of experience they feel like they're on
the edge of experience
uh somehow appropriating it from the
side either kind of on the edge of the
world and the world is out there your
body is is in some sense an object in
the world uh which you you know you it's
different from the world you know the
the boundary of your skin is still
meaningful you can sort of loosely
control your body I mean you can't
control you can control your growth you
know and and subtle you know voluntary
motor movements but
uh you can't you're not controlling
everything your body is doing you're not
controlling your heartbeat and your you
know your
um hormonal secretions and all of that
and so there's a lot that's going on
that is in the dark for you
and
then you you give someone an instruction
to meditate say and you say okay let's
examine all of this from the first
person side let's look for this thing
you're calling I
and again I is not identical to the body
people feel like their hands are out
there and they're good when if they're
going to meditate they're going to close
their eyes very likely and now they're
going to pay attention to something
they're going to pay attention to the
breath or the sounds and it's from the
point of view of being a locus of
attention that is now aiming attention
strategically at an object like the
breath
um that there's this dualism that is set
up and
ultimately the ultimate promise of
meditation I mean they're really two
levels at which you could be interested
in in meditation
um one is you know very straightforward
and remedial and non-paradoxical and
very well subscribed and it's it's the
usual set of claims about all the
benefits you're going to get from
meditation right so you're going to
lower your stress and you're going to
increase your focus and you're gonna you
know Stave off cortical thinning and
there's all kinds of good things that
science is saying meditation will will
give you
um
and none of that entails really drilling
down on this paradoxical claim that the
self is an illusion or anything else of
that sort
but from my point of view
the real purpose of meditation and its
real promise is not in this long list of
of benefits and uh you know I'm not
discounting any of those though you know
the science for many of them is quite
provisional
um it's in this deeper claim that if you
look for this thing you're calling I if
you look for the sense that there's a
thinker in addition to the the the
mirror rising of the next thought say
you won't find that thing and and you
can what's more you cannot find it in a
way that's conclusive uh and that
matters right and and it has a there's a
host of benefits that follow from that
Discovery
um which are
uh
quite a bit deeper and more interesting
than engaging meditation on the side of
its benefits you know de-stressing
increasing focus and all the rest
I have a number of questions related to
what you just said and uh first of all I
I agree that the evidence that
meditation can improve focus reduce
stress Etc it's there it's um not an
enormous pile of evidence but it's
growing and I think that especially for
some of the shorter meditations which I
these days view more as perceptual
exercises you know uh talked about this
on the podcast before but for those that
haven't heard it before about you know
perception you can have extra reception
extending
things beyond the confines of your skin
interception which is I think also
includes the surfaces of the skin but
everything inward
um and meditation through eyes closed
typically involving some sort of
attentional spotlighting something we'll
get into uh to more interceptive versus
extrasceptive events Etc including
thoughts
and so I think of
at a basic level meditation as a
somewhat of a perceptual exercise
um you can tell me where you disagree
there and I I would expect and hope that
you would
um but I would like to just touch on
this idea that you brought up because
it's such an interesting one of this
idea that our bodies are containers and
that we
um somehow view ourselves as passengers
within those containers that's certainly
been my experience
um and the image that I have is of uh as
you say that is of myself or of people
out there that sit a few centimeters
below the surface or that sit entirely
in their head and of course the brain
and body are connected through the
nervous system I think sometimes a brain
is used to replace the nervous system
and that can get us into trouble in
terms of coming up with real real
directions and definitions but
the point is that there is something
special about the real estate in the
head I think for as much as my
laboratory and many other scientists are
are really interested in brain body
connections through the nervous system
and other organ systems of the that the
nervous system binds that if you cut off
all my limbs
I'm going to be different but I'm
fundamentally still Andrew whereas if we
were to lesion a you know a couple
Square millimeters out of my parietal
cortex
um it's an open question as to whether
or not I would still seem as much like
Andrew to other people into myself even
and so there's something fundamentally
different about the real estate in the
cranial Vault uh right you can even
remove both of my eyes I'd still be
Andrew and those are two pieces of my
central nervous system that are
fundamental to my daily life but I'd
still be me whereas
um and this doesn't I think just apply
to memory systems I mean I think there
are regions of the frontal cortex that
when destroyed have been shown to modify
personality and self-perception in
dramatic ways so it's a sort of obvious
Point once it's made but I do think it's
worth um
highlighting because there does seem to
be something special about being in the
head the other thing is that
um
sitting a few centimeters below the
surface or riding in this container
makes sense to me except I I wonder if
you've ever experienced a shift as I
have when something very extreme happens
let's use the negative example of you
know all of a sudden you're in a fear
State all of a sudden it feels as if
your entire body is is you or is me and
is and and now I need to get this thing
the whole container and me to some place
of safety in whatever form
um this is also true I think in ecstatic
States yeah where you can feel really
when people say embodied I wonder
whether or not we normally oscillate
below the surface of our body when I say
oscillate I mean in neural terms I mean
maybe our sensory experience is not
truly at the bodily surface but sits
below the bodily surface more at the
level of organ systems and within our
head and then certain things that jolt
us our autonomic nervous system into
heightened States bring us into states
of
um you know bring us closer to the
surface and therefore include all of us
again I don't want to take us down a
mechanistic description of of something
that doesn't exist but does any of that
resonate um in terms of how you are
thinking about or describing the self
yeah yeah there's a lot there first on
the point of the brain being you know
the locus of of what we are as Minds
um yeah I mean they're people who will
insist that sort of the whole nervous
system has to be thought of as when
you're talking about our emotional life
and you know you know the the
um the insula's connection to uh the gut
and you just so that the the sense of of
self extends beyond the brain but I I
totally take your point that a brain
transplant is a coherent idea and you
would expect to go with the brain rather
than with the viscera and
um so in that sense we really are the
the old philosophical thought experiment
of being a brain and a vat I mean we
essentially are already you know the vat
is our skull and we're you know
virtually in that situation
um horrible movie I'm sorry I can't help
but interrupt when I was a a teenager my
sister and I used to go to the movies
every once in a while we'd trade off who
could pick the movie and um
she took me to see once the movie Boxing
Helena the David Lynch film I never saw
that where he amputates the limbs of a
woman who he's obsessed by and keeps her
it's a really horrible film and about 20
minutes into it my sister just turned to
me and said I'm
sorry and the question then was whether
or not two siblings should actually
persist in a movie like that right we
decided to persist in the movie so that
we could laugh about it later but it was
rather disturbing I don't recommend the
movie nor do I recommend seeing it with
a sibling but in that movie that the
woman he he takes her as a container and
restricts her movement right quite
sadistic and horrible thing really
um David Lynch
um interesting mind perhaps but the the
idea was that uh was to question how
much of the person persists in the
absence of their ability to move Etc
could there be love could there be these
other affections um anyway a rather
extreme example but
um one that I that still haunts me and I
suppose I'm thinking about still yeah
yeah well so but just to follow that
point
um
there's a there's a lot about us that we
don't have access to
unless we enact it physically like you
know if I ask you you know do you still
know how to ride a bike right there's no
place in your memory where you can you
can inspect by you know just sitting in
your chair that you you've retained the
knowledge of how to ride a bike right
like a procedural memory is different
from semantic or episodic memory if I
asked you you know do you know do you
know your address yes you can recall
your address just sitting there but if
you if you had had a micro stroke that
neatly dissected out your ability to
ride a bike you know and left everything
else intact you know you might think you
could ride a bike but suddenly you stand
up next to one and you have no idea what
to do with it and that would be a
discovery that would only happen if you
were rhetorically engaged with that you
know object
um and I'm sure there's you know we
could probably come up with a hundred
things about us that really seem core to
us and we you know and are not separable
for our you know from our you know
personhood which
seemed to only cut you know only get
invoked when we're you know out there
moving in the world and you know we have
limbs Etc
um and uh
but yeah no it's the the seat of
of
Consciousness I mean
the right framework to talk about all
this from my point of view is
consciousness and its contents right so
we have Consciousness the fact that
there's something that is like to be us
right the fact that that the the world
and our internal experience is is
illuminated that it has a qualitative
character
um and then there's a question of what
is that qualitative character what is it
you know what kinds of information do we
have access to what does it feel like to
be us how do how do different states of
arousal change that so you talked about
fear yeah I mean fear can change a lot
of things but
um
uh and you know various neurological
deficits or you know you know you can
add drugs to the mix you had
psychedelics that you radically
transform the contents of Consciousness
from my point of view Consciousness
itself is simply the the cognizance the
awareness this that that
is the the floodlights by which any of
that stuff appears right so
um Consciousness doesn't change but its
contents change and to come back to
meditation for a second many people
think meditation is about changing the
contents of Consciousness there's some
kind of some contents you want to get
rid of like anxiety other contents you
want to to encourage like calm and you
know unconditional love or some other
you know classically Pleasant pro-social
emotion
um and that's all fine that's all
possible but the real the wisdom of you
know the the 2000 year old wisdom of
meditation that really is the you know
the chewy center of the the toasty pop
is a recognition of what Consciousness
itself is always already like regardless
of the contents and the changes in
Contents and this is why I mean we might
talk about this but this is why they're
mutually compatible uh psychedelics and
meditation for me are somewhat
orthogonal because psychedelics is all
about making wholesale changes to the
contents of Consciousness and and
there's a you know some wonderful
consequences of doing that there can be
some harrowing and terrifying
consequences of doing that but uh
generally speaking I think you know you
used used wisely they can be incredibly
valuable and and
the therapeutic potential there is
enormous but
The crucial disjunction here is that
there really is something to recognize
about ordinary waking consciousness that
the Consciousness that's compatible with
my driving a car to get here on time
right you don't have to you don't have
to have the pyrotechnics of being on LSD
to see the the
the to transcend the central illusion
that I'm I'm saying is is the thing to
be transcended which is the sense that
there is a duality between subject and
object in every moment of experience
and to take it back to something you
said about just all of our different
modes in ordinary life
the interesting thing is I think people
are constantly losing their sense of
self
and they're not aware of it and I mean
there there's a
um probably an analogy to the visual
system here which is
um to visual cycades which perhaps
you've spoken about at some point on
your podcast not enough so please yeah
um so so what happens with our you know
every time we move our eyes this is
called a a sakad and we do that about
you know three times a second or so uh
just normally
um there is a you know the the region of
motor cortex that that affects that
movement sends what's called an efferent
copy of that motor movement uh which is
which is used as information that
propagates back to visual cortex that
suppresses uh the data of vision while
the eyes are moving because otherwise if
you weren't doing that every time you
moved your eyes it would seem like the
visual scene itself was lurching around
and people can experience this for
themselves if they just you know touch
one of their eyeballs on the side you
know not all that hard and kind of
Jiggle It you know and I think you can
roll it around you can Jiggle It from
side to side you can see that a a
um a movement of the eyeball that's not
governed by your ocular motor system
delivers a jiggling of the world because
it's not your brain is not anticipating
it in the same way and it's not you're
not producing that that same uh you know
predictive copy of of the movement it's
a little bit like um uh we have some
action sports filmers on our staff here
that the gimbal you know that holds a an
iPhone like you see the kids on the
surfboards or skateboards or something
they're gonna hold a phone while moving
around or the people who the vloggers
does anyone even still use that for
example
um moving around and to it's it's image
stabilization essentially
um that keeps the the camera steady and
these are more than cameras of course
the for those listening pointing at my
eyes but they do far more than just what
a camera would do but yeah this internal
system of of image stabilization yeah I
can see perhaps where you're going with
this
um that that
it allows us to remain in a
self-referencing scheme as opposed to
um sort of paying attention to just how
confusing it is to to track the visual
world at some level well actually where
I'm going is it so people are having the
suppression of vision three times a
second on average and they're not
experiencing it right so like you're
like you're literally like you're you're
effectively going blind
and you're not noticing it and
um just very fast yes it's very fast now
there's an analogous uh suppression I
would say of the sense of self that
occurs every time
attention gets absorbed
significantly in its object right so
like we even have this concept of you
know losing yourself in your work or you
know you're losing your the classic flow
experiences have this this quality where
there's the and this this tends to be
why they're so rewarding
um where there's just if you're in in
some you know athletic activity or you
know an aesthetic one
um uh or you could be having sex or you
could be whatever it is some Peak
experience it's peakness usually entails
there being some brief period where
there was no distance between you and
the experience right for that moment you
were no longer looking over your own
shoulder or anticipating the next moment
or trying to get somewhere where you
weren't or you know micromanaging errors
or like this you know there's not
there's just the flow of unity with
whatever the the you know whatever the
experience is you know a surfer on on
the wave right
um and we love those experiences
um and then
we are continually
abstracted away from them by our
thinking about them we were thinking oh
my God that was so good or how do I get
back to that or you know you're looking
at a sunset it's the most beautiful
sunset you've ever seen
and then you're continually interrupting
the experience of merely seeing it with
a commentary about how amazing this is
and I wonder you know what a real estate
prices are here I mean is it possible
that we could we could move here and
like your your mind is just continually
narrating a conversation you're having
with yourself however paradoxically I
mean you're telling yourself something
yourself things that you already know
uh as though there were two of you
rather often right like you know you're
just you know I'm looking for um you
know which is the water and it's oh
there it is right but like I'm the one
seeing it who am I saying oh the you
know there it is too as though there's
someone else who needs to be informed
about the thing I already saw right so
it's it's um there's something about our
internal dialogue that is paradoxical
um is there any um neurologic condition
um
or anything like that where somehow
people feel more unified with the cell
phone in a continual basis
um The Observer and the actor within
whether it
stay more more
um as a complete sentence is there any
known neurological syndrome makes it
sound like a bad thing but it could be a
good thing whereby people feel that the
actor and the Observer within them are
unified continually there's not a
pathological one some of them the work
on the default mode Network suggests
that that's at least part of the story
right so the default mode Network
uh which has been talked about a lot of
late because it has come up both in the
in the meditation literature and in the
Psychedelic literature but it's original
uh Discovery was that you know and the
reason why it was called the default
mode was is that in virtually every
neuroimaging experiment ever run they
found that between tasks when the brain
was just in its default State the these
these midline structures would would
increase their activity and then they
would then they would reliably diminish
whenever the person in the scanner was
was on task and usually that meant some
kind of outward looking
um you know visual discrimination task I
mean but it could be it could be you
know it could be visual it could be
semantic it could be but there it tends
to be their eyes are open and they're
paying attention to something that's
being broadcast to them through you know
monitor goggles
um or you know they're looking at a
mirror that's showing them a computer
monitor
um but the so the general Insight was
there are these midline structures in
the brain that seem to be increasing
their activity when the brain is just
kind of idling between tasks waiting for
something to happen
um and then further experiments found
tasks that actually upregulated
um activity there Beyond Baseline and
those tasks seem to be
self-referential so that when you ask
people you know you give them a list of
words and you say well do these any any
of these apply to you right you know and
so people are or you ask people to think
about
um
uh you know actually in one experiment I
did when you you know when you're
challenging people's beliefs uh when
you're challenging beliefs that that
have more of a personal significance
like political or religious beliefs you
get an up regulation in these regions as
opposed to just generic beliefs about
you know you're in Los Angeles this is a
table you know there's something to
which you know people are not you know
uh holding fast as a matter of identity
um
so anyway both meditation and
psychedelics seem to suppress activity
in these in these regions which we know
are associated with both self-talk mind
wandering and and explicit acts of
self-representation right so could we
say that they are somewhat
autobiographical because they Access
Memory systems and in the way you're
describing them and in the way that a
colleague of mine who's been a guest on
this podcast I don't know if you've
interacted with them before but I think
you'd very much enjoy whatever
interaction you would have as um David
Spiegel he's our associate chair of
psychiatrist he and his father actually
his father then he founded
um hypnosis as a valid clinical practice
in Psychiatry and hypnosis which is
obviously a heightened sense of
attention with deep relaxation is known
to dramatically suppress the the default
mode network uh he talks about this a
lot and I I always wonder as we
um
take down activity within the default
mode Network what surface is it in its
place and is what surfaces is in its
place
um does that somehow reflect that the
two are normally in a push-pull because
that's not necessarily the case right
when I fall asleep I can hallucinate but
that doesn't mean that during the day my
uh the fact that I'm looking at objects
is is what's preventing me from
hallucinating if I close my eyes I can
get imagery but you know there's this
kind of a a different illusion the
illusion of antagonistic circuitry
sometimes
um I don't want to take us off course
but the default mode Network seems to
um want to be there quote unquote it
seems to be fighting for for our
attention
um unless we give ourselves a visual
Target or an auditory Target or some
Salient experience of some kind it
sounds like and then if
um I'm surprised to hear that meditation
reduces activity in the default mode
Network at some level because meditation
to me oftentimes involves um paying
attention to a some sort of perceptual
Target yeah maybe you could um
eventually explain as to how it might do
that or why it might yeah and I don't
think it's the whole story because
obviously outward going attention is not
um even if you're having the kind of
egoic sakad that I'm talking about where
you're like you're actually not clearly
aware of of yourself you're not clearly
defining yourself as separate from
experience uh for the moment of paying
attention so you are sort of losing
yourself in your work that's not the
same thing as having the clear
meditative Insight of selflessness that
I'm that I'm claiming is the goal of
meditation
um
but there is a you know to wind back to
the original point I was making and the
reason why I drew the ref the analogy to
visual psychods I do think there's a
continuous interruption in our sense of
self that goes unrecognized and
um
but but the conscious
uh
acquisition of of the understanding that
the self is an illusion is a different
experience and it's because it you're
you're then you're then focusing on this
absence actually there's another analogy
to you know the visual system that
applies here
which is to the the optic blind spot I
mean it's like so
um which is a good analogy for me
because it cuts through a bunch of false
assumption as to where we kind of where
that you would look for this or how this
relates to ordinary experience
so as many people know that we have you
know in both eyes we have What's called
the blind spot which is a consequence of
the optic nerve transiting through the
retina I mean unlike uh cephalopods I
think I mean I think cephalopods have
their optic nerve you know as you know a
an omniscient being would have
engineered it
connecting the retina from the back and
therefore there is no blinds the area of
blindness associated with its Transit
back through the retinal receptors on
the outside exactly yeah humans for
whatever reason uh put photos well yes I
always say I wasn't consoled the design
phase something uh put photoreceptors
um combination of things put
photoreceptors in the back and so you
actually have to send the highway of
information through through the pixel
center of the of the eye yeah
cephalopods and uh drosophila basically
um uh invertebrates right uh the design
is more at its face logical mammal
very illogical design at least as far as
our judgments yeah but it gives it gives
me a good analogy so I'll I'll take it
I'd like to take a brief break and
acknowledge our sponsor athletic greens
athletic greens is an all-in-one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink that also
contains digestive enzymes and
adaptogens I started taking athletic
Greens Way back in 2012 so that's 10
years now of taking athletic greens
every single day so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring this podcast the
reason I started taking athletic greens
and the reason I still take athletic
greens is that it covers all of my
foundational nutritional needs so
whether or not I'm eating well or enough
or not I'm sure that I'm covering all of
my needs for vitamins minerals
probiotics adaptogens to combat stress
and the digestive enzymes really help my
digestion I just feel much better when
I'm drinking athletic greens if you'd
like to try athletic greens you can go
to athleticgreens.com huberman and for
the month of January they have a special
offer where they'll give you 10 free
travel packs plus a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 vitamin D 3 and K2 are
vital for immune function metabolic
function Hormone Health but also calcium
regulation and heart health again that's
athletic greens.com huberman to claim
their special offer in the month of
January of 10 free travel packs plus a
year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so in any
case we have this blind spot which you
can I think most people learn this in
school although my daughters had not
been taught this in school I just showed
them this for the first time like a
month ago which and they were briefly
fascinated and they want to return to
their screen time but uh anyway you can
take a piece of paper and you make you
know two marks on it and then you cover
one eye and you fixate on on one Mark
um I mean you can look this up online if
you need uh details about how to do this
and you while staring at one fixation
point you move the paper back and forth
and you can get it to a place where the
other Mark disappears and that and if
and you know you can run this experiment
long enough to satisfy yourself that
there is in fact a blind spot in your
visual field which you with one eye
closed you don't normally notice the
reason why you have to cover cover one
eye is because each eye compensates for
the the blind spot or the other so
um but which is to say that if you close
one eye and and Survey the visual scene
something really is missing whatever
you're looking at if you're looking at a
crowd of people somebody is missing
ahead and you're not noticing it and
it's not it's not easy to notice because
um
you know the brain doesn't tend
to vividly represent the absence of
information I mean it's just like this
is part of the game that's not being
rendered it's not it's not showing up as
a a break in your in the visual field
it's just not there and you're
um I mean the people have argued that
there's a a kind of filling in
phenomenon that happens but I think that
can be you know misunderstood or
exaggerated but the eye movements
themselves that you described before I I
guess I should say that the the sakad
analogy of about
um transiently and repetitively erasing
the self works perfectly here because
indeed Microsoft's a little smaller
cicada occur all the time also prevent
our eyes from fixating in one location
for long enough to observe our blind
spot even if one eye is closed right
right so if we uh the experiment's done
with paralytics to essentially lock eyes
in one location basically things just
start disappearing yeah
hallucinating but actually we start
going blind right and those experiments
have been done and on humans uh here
they're quite terrifying yeah yeah yeah
but I mean you can do that for yourself
too it just you know it begins to just
off Melt Away in a warm glow
um no psychedelics required
but
the um the interesting point there is
that when you ask yourself okay so this
because of the as a consequence of the
eyes Anatomy there's this this thing you
can see uh you know that is absent from
your experience
but the question is
where is that in relationship to the
rest of you to your mind is that deep
within or is that in some sense right on
the surface of experience and there's a
there's expectation that people have
again I think conflating meditation with
with a search for changes in the context
of Consciousness they're looking for you
know you know
um much more subtle things to to notice
about the mind or much you know vaster
things to notice
um psychedelics sets up this this
expectation that you know you you do you
know a massive dose of mushrooms or LSD
and everything changes I mean you just
get the this full you know beatific
Vision
um and you know you get not only visual
changes but you know emotional changes
and and you get
synesthesia where like you're just you
have much more mind in in in so many
ways
um so they begin you you having these
experiences or reading the mystical
literature you begin to think okay well
then freedom is
is really elsewhere or is is really it's
deep within it's like it's not it's not
coincident with the ordinary awareness
that chemicals that can see this coffee
cup clearly and that can just transition
attention to you know reading an email
uh you know with the sort of full
sobriety of just you know you know
ordinary waking consciousness
um
but the truth is this insight into
selflessness is insight into the
non-duality of subject and object
is as close to ordinary Consciousness as
this insight into the optic blind spot
like what where do you have to go to
have this insight into the blind spot no
you just have to you have to go anywhere
you just have to set up the the
experiment correctly such that
you know you you can see the data
but the data is right on the surface
it's like it's it's almost too close to
you to notice I mean if it's at all hard
to notice it because it's because it's
so close rather than it's you know deep
within or far away
um and there are other analogies like um
I don't remember those Mind's Eye pieces
of artwork that were the random dot
stereograms we have an image that pops
out
um I always find it very difficult to
see those because I have you know very
dominant eye you know but some people
people can't see those these are these
images that used to be at the kind of
like touristy shops but people say oh
there it is the whale I'm thinking I
don't see it
um you know kids that swim a lot when
they're younger and they're I tend to
breathe just to one side I don't know if
this was you this was definitely me they
tend to um will keep one eye closed you
set up a pretty strong ocular dominance
biasing your vision to one or the other
eye early in life whether or not you're
learning how to be a bow hunter or
you're learning how to throw darts or
shoot Billiards or anything involves
um selectively viewing the world through
one eye for even a couple of hours can
set up a permanent
um asymmetry in the waiting of a visual
flow right of flow of visual information
from the eye to the brain um it's
reversible but only through the reverse
gymnastics of covering up the other eye
intentionally so I actually I had to be
reverse patched for a while because I
was seeing double because I lost
binocular vision I don't stand a chance
in hell of
seeing an image pop out of a random yeah
which is kind of ironic because I did my
PhD on binocular circuitry right but um
and nonetheless if people can see these
um
or if they can't what I think they
provide a really terrific example of
what you're talking about as a larger
theme which is that perceptually you see
a bunch of dots and then all of a sudden
right what you thought wasn't there
suddenly there but can this disappear
again or there are certain visual
Illusions if we were to include others
that once you see them you cannot unsee
them right so there's the faces vases
you know figure ground type stuff yeah
it does but by stable First Step Yeah by
stable percepts and then they're sort of
um ocular competition you show two
different images to the eyes each of the
two eyes it is near impossible for
people to perceive them both
simultaneously yeah um so it's a little
bit of what you're describing I mean
these seem to be fundamental features
about the way the neural circuits are
organized that they don't want to stably
they don't want to stay fixated on any
one thing for very long to do so either
takes training intense interest intense
fear intense excitement and I say
intense I guess I come back to this idea
that the autonomic nervous system is
somehow governing our ability to
um Spotlight at any one location for
very long does that is that a useful
framework or is that going to take us
down a different way it's sort of a
different path for this I mean for the
only point I was making is that
the seemingly paradoxical claim that
something can be right on the surface
uh and yet hard to see
right so like that there are things that
are um because it's and again this this
this
seems to justify the expectation held by
I would think you know the vast majority
of people who get interested in these
you know spiritual things for lack of a
better word
um
that the truth must somehow be deep
within right like that like there's
really like a there's some distance
between where you're between the one who
is looking and the thing that has to be
found right and you have to go through
this this long evolution of changes I
mean there's many metaphors that set
this up it's like you're at the base of
a mountain and you have to climb to the
top and so you have to find the PATH
however secure secured us to get you
there
um but there really is a distance
between where you're between your
starting point and the goal and what I'm
arguing uh you know and this is a kind
of a non-dual you know to use a term of
jargon
um
this is a non-dual approach to
meditation as opposed to a dualistic one
that there really is a a the the path
and the goal are are are coincident
right that there's a there that you have
to unravel the logic by which you would
seek something that's outside of you the
you know the the present moment's
experience
um you know I.E not available really not
available to you now
um because so many things worth having
so many so many skills worth acquiring
really are not available to you now it's
like it's like you know if you want to
be a Pianist or if you want to speak
Chinese or you want like like the you
there's something you don't know and
then you want to learn that thing and
there's a whole process right and you
might not be capable of doing it right
you might and and real Mastery is far
away right if you if you've never hit a
golf ball and you want to hit a golf
ball 300 yards straight right you know I
can pretty much guarantee you're not
going to do that initially and you're
not going to do it you know on day two
and uh you're not gonna do it reliably
for the longest time and there's real
training you know in front of you to to
be able to do that reliably
an insight into
and really the core Insight I mean the
Insight that is either the core of you
know the Buddha's teaching to take one
one
historical example of this
um really is available now and it is not
I mean you know granted it can be very
hard one for people I mean I had
probably spent a year on silent retreat
in in you know one week to three month
increments before I
sort of got the point I'm making now
right so like I you know it's quite it's
I mean literally and this is these are
you know these are Retreats where you
spend you know 12 to 18 hours a day just
meditating trying to to you know unpack
the kinds of claims I'm I'm you know
making now
um
so there it's pot it's it's possible to
rigorously overlook this it's possible
to stand in front of the Mind's Eye
image and stare in a way that is
guaranteed not to give you pop out right
and to be to be Adept at you know
staring in that way
um so it's possible to be misled and so
what I'm what I'm trying to argue here
is that there's
um
there's a fair amount of Leverage you
can get with with better information
which can kind of cut the time course if
you're searching for this thing and and
kind of cancel your false expectations
about just where this is in relation to
your ordinary waking consciousness
um and it's possible to get bad
information and to have a bunch of
experiences you know you go out you go
and do an Ayahuasca trip and you have
it's incredibly valuable and it's
valuable for all the ways in which it
change the contents of your
Consciousness in in you know startling
ways and you had insights into your past
and into your relationships and into why
you're not as loving as you might be and
there's lots to think about and you're
like okay that's all great that's all
something that you know we can talk
about but
there is it truly is orthogonal and if
it makes a point of contact to what I'm
talking about it's really interesting
one point you know and it's at the point
where
this sense of of subject object division
in Consciousness is illusory and
vulnerable to investigation and if you
investigate it as sort of the right
plane of focus you know you pick the
analogy you want from you know whether
it's you know setting up the the
um
the optic blind spot experiment in just
the right way so that you can see that
you know it's actually not the data is
not there or
um I mean the bi-stable percept is is
great because
you know when you see one of these
images like the vase face
um diagram or you know the dalmatian you
know that it looks like just a mess of
dots and then you see the the image of a
Dalmatian dog pop out once you see it
you really can't unsee it I mean like
once you have the the requisite
conceptual you know anchor to it then
every time you look you're going to find
it again and and it eventually becomes
effortless and that's what ultimately
meditation is I mean this kind of
meditation you you ultimately learn to
recognize
that there's no separation from you
between you and your experience right
there's not the experience on the one
hand and the self on the other
there's just experience right there's
just seeing hearing smelling tasting
touching thinking feeling you know
appropriate deception add whatever
channels of information you want to that
but
there's just the there's just the
totality of the energy of Consciousness
and its contents and there's no
it's not that you're on the riverbank
uh and this is this is how it can seem
in the beginning even when you're
practicing meditation fairly diligently
it can seem like you're on the riverbank
watching the contents of Consciousness
Flow by and then and meditation is the
act of doing that
more and more dispassionately so you're
no longer grabbing at the at the
pleasant or pushing the unpleasant way
you're just kind of relaxing and then in
the most non-judgmental frame of mind
just witnessing the flow right but if
you're doing that dualistically
you feel like the meditator you feel
like the subject aiming attention and so
now you're on the riverbank watching
everything go go past but the truth is
you are the river right experience
itself is that there is just experience
itself you're not you're not on the edge
of experience and everything you can
notice is part of the of the flow right
and there's and there's no point from
which you to abstract yourself away from
the flow
to stand outside it and to say okay this
is this is my life this is my experience
this is my body yes you can do that I
mean those are all just thoughts but
that's more of the flow right and so
there is a
there's a process by which you would
eventually eventually recognize that
there's no distance between you and your
experience and again you can you can
wait for those moments in life where
experience gets so good or so terrifying
you know it's just so Salient right your
amygdala is driving so hard I mean so
you're in a war and you can't think
about anything because you know the
enemy's shooting at you and this is the
most thrilling video game you've ever
played in your life and your life is on
the line or you're you're you know at
the peak of of some you know athletic
event where there's just you don't know
how you're doing the things you're doing
but it's all happening automatically
right
um but you know those are those are you
know 1 100th of one percent of one's
life you know and
you know what I'm calling meditation is
a way of Simply
understanding the mechanics of attention
whereby you are denying yourself that
Unity of experience so much of the time
and recognizing that that's you know
it's it's based on a a misperception of
of the way Consciousness uh always
already is well if there wasn't an
incentive to learn how to meditate
properly
um
that was one and I've been meditating
for a fair amount since I was in my
teens but more along the lines of just
paying attention to breath and
um you know recognize thoughts sort of
Observer open Observer type meditation
or focused attention I would suppose
more of the focused attention type we'll
get into these a little bit later but I
have a number of questions related to
what you just said sure
um
I love the idea that
this thing that um we would all do well
to uh
understand to observe Consciousness
itself as opposed to
um trying to alter the contents of
consciousness
May sit much closer to us than
um one might think that it
um and that
because it sits so close to us that that
might be one of the reasons why we miss
it I go right to a visual system an
example I mean if you don't if you're
wearing corrective lenses and there's a
speck on your lens you know typically
you're looking out through the lens and
so you wouldn't observe that spec
um any number of different analogies
could work here the the fact that there
are states however few
um positive and negative ecstasy 8
extreme ecstasy and extreme fear uh
being the the two I think most obvious
ones it seems like we agree on that
allow us to capture the sense of
um completeness of self or the the unity
of the The Observer and the and the
actor
um
the fact that those are are seldom for
the non-trained for the non-meditator
um suggests to me two things I think one
um perhaps worth exploring more than the
other but one is that
um
what's really being revealed in the
states where we can feel the unity of
the Observer and the actor is
understanding something fundamental
about the algorithm that not the online
algorithm but the algorithm that is our
nervous system just as a you mentioned
cephalopods I mean mantis shrimp C an
enormous array of color Hues that we
don't right they're map they're maps and
representations of the world are
fundamentally different pit vipers see
in the infrared
we're restricted to somewhat of a
limited range within the color spectrum
but still more vast than that of dogs or
cats okay
so understanding that for seeing what
um a pit viper can see for moments would
be informative
um perhaps
um sensing heat emissions uh as a human
might be invasive then maybe that's why
we don't do it so the question is to
just make it straightforward is
um
why would the system be designed this
way again neither of us were to
consulted the design phase but that
brings me to perhaps the more tractable
question was which is
um about development I mean I'm a great
believer that the neural circuits that
encouraged uh healthy parent-child
relations or unhealthy parent child
relations as the case may be in
childhood stem from the initial demands
of internal versus external states which
is exactly what we're talking about
which is that a young child feels
anxious because it needs a diaper change
it doesn't really know it needs its
diaper change or it's cold where it's
uncomfortable or it's hungry where it's
overly full and so it vocalizes and then
some external Source comes to us and
relieves that hopefully right and so the
fundamental rule that we first learn is
not that we have a self or that
um Things fall down not up but is that
when uncomfortable
um externalize that discomfort and it
will be relieved by an outside player
and then of course there's a repurposing
of that circuitry for adult romantic
attachments I don't think anyone doubts
that and that can explain a lot indeed
about attachment and so forth
so something about our developmental
wiring and the algorithms that these
neural circuits run tend to bias most
people the non-practiced meditators to
live a somewhat functional life at least
um
without this awareness of actor and
observer right and so what you're really
talking about is a deliberate
intervention
to understand and resolve that Gap in
the algorithm is that do I have that
right yeah I'm more or less restating
what you said in a way that I'm I'm
hoping will serve as a jumping off point
I said you know why questions are always
very dangerous in biology or any yeah
you know yeah
um and relationship what's that or in
relationships or in relationship right
exactly
um although I think it all does really
hearken back to this early developmental
wiring which of course is modifiable
that's the that's the beauty of of the
the nervous system is it's the one organ
that seems to be able to change itself
at least to some degree
um
so what are your thoughts about the
organization of the circuitry to to
essentially under normal conditions to
not reveal it's what seems to be one of
its more important and profound and
um for you know dare I say enlightening
features right it's almost as if we are
potentially like mantis shrimp we can
see so many more colors than we actually
see and yet we don't we we sort of most
people opt not to and I would argue that
um one of the great strengths of the
waking up app for instance is that it it
essentially walks you through the
process of being able to arrive at these
things without having to go do one year
or three year
um long silent meditation Retreats yeah
so if you could just elaborate for a
moment before we move on about you know
what are your thoughts about how the
circuitry is arranged by default versus
the the and and what that means
um for there to be an intervention that
we have to intervene in the self in
order to reveal the self well so the two
big questions there one about Evolution
one about development so
um
with respect to Evolution I mean it's
important to recognize that evolution
doesn't see our deepest concerns about
human flourishing and human well-being
you know it's all about the office it's
just you know you we are set up to spawn
and to survive long enough to to help
our progeny spawn if we can do that and
that and then that's it right and so
anything that was good for that
including you know uh tribalism and
xenophobia and you know
um you know all kinds of hardware and
software flaws that are that are reveal
themselves to be flaws in the present
time when we're trying to build a viable
Global civilization
um but you know they they redounded to
the advantage of our ancestors somehow
um or they just there's there are things
about us that we're simply not selected
for they just kind of came along for the
ride you know the you know what Stephen
J Gould called a spandrel you know um
so
we are not set up by Evolution to be as
happy as we possibly can be
um and certainly and and to do almost
anything that interests us well I mean
we're not set up by Evolution to be
mathematicians or musicians or to to
create democracies that are healthy I
mean Evolution can see none of this and
we are doing these things based on
cognitive and emotional Hardware
uh that we are leveraging in New
Directions right I mean we have we are
primates and we are you know we're
communicating with you know small mouth
noises I mean we're language using
primates and all of that has clearly
evolved
um
uh and we're doing these amazing things
including science you know however
improbably where you were actually able
to to you know almost entirely with
language uh understand reality that at a
scale that exceeds Us in both directions
I mean the very the very vast and the
very small and and you know also
temporally the very old uh we have you
know visions of the far future we can
figure out you know where and you know
an asteroid is going to you know cross
Earth's orbit a thousand years from now
uh if we just do the math and it's
amazing that we can do all those things
but evolution is blind to all of that
right and so
we have
in terms of what we care about and
certainly in terms of what we what's
going to ensure our survival as a
species we have flown the perch that was
created for us by Evolution I mean we're
just not it's not just the primate
things and
so so it is with learning how to
regulate our emotions and and you know
punch through to a self-concept or
Beyond a self-concept that is more
normative psychologically that allows us
to you know not be um terrorized by our
apish genes uh as fully as we seem to be
even in the presence of more and more
destructive technology that I mean look
like you know we're
we're still practically chimpanzees
armed with nuclear weapons right and
that is you know increasingly
dysfunctional and uh very soon we're
going to be in the presence of minds or
apparent Minds that we have built you
know that are as intelligent as we are
or and very quickly you know probably 15
minutes after that far more intelligent
than we are and
so what we do with all of that is again
something that we have to figure out
based on
the minds we have the minds we can build
the minds we can change you know we can
we can meddle with our own genomes now
and and that will produce its own
consequences uh you know in ourselves
and uh in future Generations if we've
meddled with the germline and again all
of that is just you know you know
evolution is just sort of the womb we
came out of but it's not it didn't
anticipate any of that right so so that
you know Mother Nature has simply not
had our best interests at heart right
and it's we might die off and and from
the point of view of Mother Nature
that's that's fine because 99 of every
species dies off you know
um
so there's that but when you're talking
when you're talking about the the
individual developmentally so you know
we all come into this world again as a
as a um fairly hairless primate that
needs a tremendous amount of Care by
others and
um the logic of that is that
um
you know you know the reason why we're
not a gazelle that can you know run you
know 45 minutes later and then basically
do all the gazelle things uh perfectly
uh soon thereafter
um the reason why we have you know we
have this this time of of immaturity
uh and that becomes has become
functional for us is it it's just we
we're we're far more flexible and we can
learn based on the needs of of an
environment to do a you know so much
more than a gazelle can and language is
a part of that and you know
um in the last
10 000 years or so culture increasingly
has been more and more a part of that
and there's a probably a layer at which
we can plausibly talk about cultural
Evolution you know and Cultural
Revolution interacting with biological
evolution to to change us
um but when you talk about the
development of an individual
each of us comes into this world I think
um not recognizing ourselves in any in
any sense that it would make sense to to
reapply
um I mean it's not that there's nothing
there I mean there could be some kind of
proto-self differentiation but I think
it's it takes a it takes a long while
and there is pro very likely
a coincidence between
really recognized it recognizing others
we recognize others first and we're
certainly in relationship immediately
and we Orient to human faces and and we
uh you know even detect
um other humans as good and bad moral
actors very early I mean certainly long
before we recognize ourselves in a
mirror we
um the experiments run again this is
Paul Bloom and and colleagues
experiments run on kind of the moral
hardware and software of of uh
developing toddlers but I think at this
point they push it down all the way to
like six months of of age where you'll
get these infants staring at kind of a
puppet show and they'll they'll show a a
um a greater interest in you know in a
classically good actors versus Bad
actors you know Cooperators versus you
know defectors in various you know
puppet show games
um
so there's it's not that we have no mind
and no
um proto-awareness of others and and of
self but what eventually happens
certainly as we become at all facile
with with language use is that we become
aware that that not only are we in
relationship to others but we are an
object in the world for them right so
that like we have enough people pointing
at us in our cribs right and impinging
Upon Our experience right you know that
you you you're being physically moved
and prodded and touched and consoled or
not consoled and just imagine what all
of these you're on the receiving end of
ten thousand interventions right and
you're completely helpless for the
longest time
um and all of that attention you have
all of these people coming up you know
to the crib and making faces at you
cheering you know and yeah and and it's
all pointed at you right so there's a
you know there's a classic magical
narcissism that that gets constructed
there if you if you
take the psychological literature you
know at least a certain strand of it
seriously
um and I think it's it's largely apt to
to think of a child at that age as a
kind a kind of um
uh
there's a kind of narcissistic structure
there where it's it's it's all kind of
going inward
and at a certain point you realize okay
I'm I'm the center of all of this right
like it's not just it's not just a a
movie that you're that you're you're you
know where you're that you're completely
absorbed in and you've lost your sense
of self I mean this is to talk about the
yet another example of
of what it's like as a grown-up to lose
our sense of self and one of the things
I think we find so fascinating by about
television and and film is that when we
get totally absorbed in it we're in this
very unusual circumstance where we're
you know our brain is basically reading
it as we're in a in the classic social
circumstance we're presented with with
you know the the facial displays of
other people in fact you know we can get
some of the sometimes these people are
10 feet tall right or their faces are 10
feet tall you leave a close-up in a
movie theater so it's like this super
stimulus in terms of of evolution and
they can make it they could be making
direct eye contact with a camera right
so you have this gigantic face staring
at you and yet you're totally
unimplicated socially you can't be seen
and you and something about that you you
know you can't be seen and so you're
completely
you completely lose self-consciousness
and yet you're you're able to examine
with completely free attention again
because you're totally unimplicated
um
the the
facial minutia and the mimetic facial
play of people uh from at a very close
range I mean you're seeing people close
I mean you have to be you know
physically just you know about to kiss
your your spouse like that's what a
close-up is in a film right like that
you never get that close to people right
um and yet here you're in a situation
where you're unobserved and you know
that and so I mean this is a bit of a
tangent but the it's the other side of
what's Happening developmentally for a
kid
um
when you're in a movie theater watching
a movie you are truly invisible and yet
you're right there seeing you know the
however heroin the human drama is you're
seeing it play out and you're seeing it
you're seeing it up close and it is a it
is in principle a social encounter that
your genes are ready for but they're not
ready for you to be invisible right and
so that's what's so uh um magical about
it but what happens developmentally for
a kid is that you're not invisible you
are an object that is constantly being
being
overrun the boundaries of your you know
you know your sensory engagement with
the world are constantly being impinged
upon by others and at a certain point
you recognize okay I'm at the center of
this and the and the way this gets
enshrined as a self
um
I think is probably coincident with our
learning The Language game we we learn
to play with others we're talking to
others people are talking to us and at a
certain point
we're talking to ourselves even when the
other people leave the room right so and
you can hear it if you ever have been
with a toddler when they're
when they're when they're externalizing
their self-talk you know you hear them
talking to themselves they're playing
and they're and they're they're having a
conversation they were talking to you
the parent but then you left the room
and and they're still talking you come
back in and they're still they're still
talking right and what happens to us
strangely
um
and this comes back to the logic of
evolution
we never stop because
Evolution never thought to build us an
off switch for this right I mean the
language is so useful and it gets tuned
up so strongly for us
and there was never a reason to shut it
off right there's never a reason to give
you this ability to say it wouldn't be
nice to have four hours of quiet now
like No self-talk
And so for most of us I mean I think
there are people who for whatever
neurological reason or you know
idiosyncratic reason undoubtedly there's
there'd be a neurological reason for it
don't have any self-talk but for them
for most of us
um we are covertly talking
basically all the time and and there's
an imagistic component of this for many
people you're visualizing things as well
but
there's just a lot a ton of white noise
in the mind that
feels a certain way and you know what I
like what you discover in meditation
ultimately is that
the self is what it feels like to be
thinking without knowing that you're
thinking right a thought arises
uninspected and seems to just become you
right so like you and I are talking now
and you know people are listening to us
they're they're struggling to follow the
train of this conversation because it is
competing with the conversation that's
happening in their heads right so I'll
be saying something and a person
listening will say
well what does that mean or like oh boy
I mean he just contradicted himself or
like you're and there's a voice in your
head that is also vying for your
attention much of the time and
um so it's you know the first discovery
people make in meditation is that it's
just so hard to pay attention to
anything the breath or a mantra or a
sound whatever it is because
you're thinking every you're thinking
about the thing you need to do in an
hour and oh it's so good that I I
downloaded this app I'm like this is
really good this is going to be good for
me but and you're but you're that
chatter isn't showing up you you're not
far back enough
uh in the in the kind of the theater of
Consciousness so as to see it emerge
it's it is just sneaking up behind you
and it feels like me again or it feels
like when someone is thinking the
thought
what the hell does that mean right
they're not seeing it as an emerging
object in Consciousness it just feels
like me it just feels that that that's
it is it the the you know subjectively
it's like the Mind contracts around this
appearance in Consciousness and it
really is just it is just us you know
it's just a sound with the voice of the
mind if you actually can inspect it it
is
it is deeply inscrutable that we ever
feel identified with our thoughts I mean
how is it that we could be a thought
these thoughts a thought just arises and
passes away and when you inspect when
you go to inspect it
it's it you know it unravels it's it's
just it's
yeah it's it's the least substantial
possible thing and and it could but yet
it could be
a thought of self-hatred you know it
could be a thought that that
unrecognized totally defines your your
mood you know it's like
um
I mean just again this this all can seem
kind of abstract but well no but I I but
I think it it's extremely concrete from
the perspective of the neural circuits
that we'll return to and maybe in a few
minutes I'd like to take a brief break
and thank our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that you get
data back about metabolic factors lipids
and hormones and so forth but you don't
know what to do with those data inside
tracker solves that problem and makes it
very easy for you to understand what
sorts of nutritional behavioral maybe
even supplementation based interventions
you might want to take on in order to
adjust the numbers of those metabolic
factors hormones lipids and other things
that impact your immediate and long-term
health to bring those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate and indeed
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker you can visit inside
tracker.com huberman and get 20 off any
of inside tracker's plans that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off if
you could elaborate a bit on this notion
of internal chatter and external stimuli
and the bridge between them because
that's I think that for some people that
might be intuitive I think for others
um
it's not so obvious that
um language is ongoing in the backdrop
Yeah because sometimes I think some
people are more tuned into
um that language for some people it's
it's louder volume for some people it's
uh more structured I have a colleague at
um
at Stanford who's been on this podcast
called diceroth who's like one of the
preeminine like bioengineers also
psychiatrist and he hasn't met he
doesn't call it a meditative practice he
has a practice where each evening after
his five kids are put down to sleep you
know yeah
um they're older now but uh and in the
quiet of the the
late hours of the night early morning he
sits and forces himself to think in
complete sentences with punctuation for
an hour this is the way that he has
taught himself to structure his thinking
right because of the very fact that
you're describing which is that
ordinarily there is an underlying
structure to what's internal but it's
disrupted by external events and it's
and these are typically it's not
um coherent enough to really make
meaning from so it's almost like
somebody sitting down to write in
complete sentences but forcing himself
to do it in his head but for many people
including myself that's a that's a
foreign experience and we only
experience structure through our
interactions with the world and other
people
that if I were I've taken the time to
try and explore ideas with eyes closed
and you know and I've been able to do
that
um there are certain pharmacologic
states that we could talk about that
facilitate that
um and know those are not amphetamines
those do exactly the opposite by the way
but
um
I think people exist in varying degrees
of structured and ex and unstructured
internal dialogue and
um in varying depths of recognition of
that internal dialogue and so the
question I suppose is is just the
recognition that there's a dialogue
ongoing internally is that itself
valuable yeah and that also can take
some time so so here's a claim I would
make that some people might find
surprising but I I think
this is an objectively true Claim about
the subjectivity of most people
which is that unless you you know have a
fair amount of training unless you just
happen to be some kind of savant in this
area which you know most people by
definition aren't
um or you have a remarkable amount of
training in what's called you know
concentration practice in in meditation
um I believe this is a a true claim that
you know if we just you put a stopwatch
on this table and and you know people
could just watch it you know the 30
seconds elapsed and
um
I set you know I said all of our
listeners or your viewers the task
uh for the next 30 seconds just pay
attention to anything your breath you
know or you know this the side of your
hand or the side of the clock or any
object
without getting lost in thought without
getting momentarily distracted by this
conversation you're having with yourself
um
this
couple things would happen one is no one
would be able to do it right and and and
not just this is not just a a
superficial inability I mean if your
life's depended on it you wouldn't be
able to do it I mean if the fate of
civilization depended on it none of none
of our listeners would be able to do
this
um
and yet some percentage of them
are are so distracted by thought
that they would think that they will
actually try this experiment and think
they succeeded right and for these
people what happens is you put them on a
Meditation Retreat and you have them
spend 12 hours a day in silence doing
nothing but this right so the practice
is just pay attention to the breath when
they're sitting and then eventually you
know you incorporate everything sounds
and other Sensations and then you
interleave that with walk-in meditation
where they're paying attention just to
the sensations of lifting and moving and
placing their feet and then you know
once the practice is going you
incorporate sounds and sites and
everything but so you can pay attention
to everything but the goal is for every
moment
um you are going to you're going to
cultivate that what this this faculty of
mine which you know increasingly is
known as mindfulness right so and
mindfulness is nothing other than this
very careful attention to the contents
of Consciousness uh but the crucial
piece is it is not
a moment of being lost in thought right
you're not you can you're not blocking
thoughts thoughts themselves can arise
but in those moments of being truly
mindful you're noticing thoughts as
thoughts whether they're whether it's
language in the mind or images you're
noticing those two as spontaneous
appearances in Consciousness
um
so
uh
if most people you know certainly anyone
who thinks they can pay attention to you
know who they can do the experiment
successfully that I just uh suggested
pay attention to something for 30
seconds without being lost in thought
you put those people on a Meditation
Retreat what they're going to experience
is you know on the first day
they're going to feel like oh yeah I was
you know I was with the breath or I was
walking you know I was with the
sensations of walking and I'd be there
for like five minutes you know solid and
then I would get lost in thought then
I'd come back and you know five more
minutes I'd be lost in thought and get
back but as the day has progressed you
know even you know 10 days into a silent
Meditation Retreat they're going to
experience
more and more distraction they're gonna
it's gonna seem like okay wait a minute
now I can't pay attention to anything
for more than five seconds right that is
progress right because because what
they're discovering is just how
distractible they are right and
um you know so something for some people
that will be immediately obvious for
some people it'll actually take a lot of
practice to realize just how distracted
they are what you just said which was
that at some point
um we
can start noticing our thoughts I can
notice my thoughts but what you're
talking about is as a goal state is not
um is not being distracted by thoughts
but actually seeing the relationship
between thoughts self and other types of
perceptions and here I think recognizing
and seeing thoughts
is a form of perception it's just an
internally directed perception
this raises a topic that um I'm
also obsessed by which I think
Neuroscience can somewhat explain but
still incomplete
um incompletely that the circuits and
mechanics Etc are not
um yet known which is about time
perception and
you know it
a simple analogy would be that um there
are a lot of small objects flying around
in the space that we happen to be having
this discussion but they're moving so
fast that I can't perceive them or
they're entirely stationary so I can't
perceive them because of the reasons we
talked about before in the visual system
my eyes are moving in perfect concert
with these with these small object
movements and therefore they are they're
I am blind to them right
a slight shift in time perception
um think of this uh perhaps as um a
change in the frame rate right camera
frame rates a faster frame rate you can
capture slow motion slower frame rate
you're going to get more of a strobe
type effect if the frame rate is low
enough right right
could it be that our
time perception is not one thing but we
have one rate of perceiving time for
external objects at a given distance
which we know is true another
frame rate for objects that are up close
we know this to be true even if those
objects are moving at the exact same
speed right I mean this would be the
sitting on a train the rungs on the
fence seem to be going by very very fast
but the ones in the distance seem to be
moving slowly this is the way the visual
system and time perception interconnect
at some level
um you're up on a skyscraper the little
ants of cars and people
um down below you know they're moving
much faster than you perceive them to
move yeah but it's it's a distance I
mean you see a plane it could be going
300 miles an hour exactly yeah and it's
not because of the lack of resolution
the lack of resolution is incidental we
know this because in animals such as um
Hawks that have twice the degree of
Acuity as far as we know they have the
same uh distance Associated shifts in
time perception so could it be that we
are running multiple streams of time
perception multiple cones of attention
that include cones of attention to our
thoughts and that somehow through
meditation we start to align the frame
rate for these different streams of
attention
so that they all fall into the same they
all fall into the same movie if you will
although it's not just a movie with
visual content what I'm doing here is uh
clearly I'm becoming a lumper rather
than a splitter I'm sure this violates
certain rules of time perception neural
circuitry but I'm not sure that it's
entirely untrue either
um and does it survive at all as a
possible model for what you're
describing and if the answer is no I'm
perfectly comfortable with that
well it's a um
it's dependent on what you mean by
meditation this is where you sort of the
particularities of what one is doing
with one's attention under the you know
the frame of meditation really matter
because there are ways to practice where
practice mindfulness in particular where
the frame rate really does seem to go
way way up right and there's actually
been some research done on this where
you take people you know before and
after a three-month silent Meditation
Retreat and you give them some kind of
visual discrimination task where they
have to like detect
um I think they used to to to to kiss
the scope is that the tool for there's
some some that presents uh
um you know like very quick pulses of
light in any case you can you can
discriminate
um
just in any in any sensory Channel I
would imagine you can make finer grain
discriminations if you're practicing
mindfulness in a very specific way which
is to be making these fine-grained
discriminations more and more and do do
nothing else for you know three months
which is which is a way of practicing so
you're so the classic you know
mindfulness practice in in what's called
vipassana meditation
is
to pay scrupulous attention to seeing
hearing smelling tasting touching
in a way that
breaks everything down into this kind of
microscopic sensory uh moments so you
know you're rather than feel your you
know your hands pressing together
what you're trying to feel with your
attention and you're feeling more and
more is all of the micro sensations of
pressure and temperature and movement uh
such that the feeling of hands
completely disappears you realize that a
hand is a concept and all you have is
this cloud of of punctate and and uh
very brief Sensations and so that so
anything you think you you have as a
datum of experience as you as you bore
into it with your attention
it it resolves into a a this kind of
diaphanous cloud of changing sensation
and that can be even even something as
as um
captivating as like a you know a serious
pain in your body I mean you have like
you know you you could have injured your
neck you know and so you have some
excruciating pain in your neck if you
just are willing to pay attention to it
you know and just pay a hundred percent
attention to it
um your a couple things happen one is
your resistance to feeling it goes away
by definition because you're now your
goal is to just pay attention to it and
and you recognize that so much of the
suffering associated with the pain was
born of a of the resistance to feeling
it you're kind of embracing against it
and all of your thinking about it you
know you think like well well you know
why did I do this to myself or when
should I see an orthopedist or how long
is this going to last and and you're you
know maybe I herniated a disc like all
of that self-talk is producing anxiety
and you know I'm not saying there's
never anything to think about there but
you know either you can do something
about it in the moment or you can't and
so much of our suffering in in the
presence of pain is the result of
resisting it worrying about it think it
is just all of the everything we're
doing with our minds but just just
feeling it right
so when you just feel it again it'll it
it breaks apart into
this this ever change ever shifting
collection of of different Sensations
and it's not one thing and it never
stays the same and it's and so two
things happen there one is there can be
tremendous a tremendous amount of relief
that happens there where you you you can
achieve a level of equanimity even in
the presence of really unpleasant if you
know physical sensation
um and this is true of mental sensation
as well this is true of emotions you
know the classically negative emotions
like anger depression or you know fear
the moment you become willing to just
feel them in all of their you know
punctate uh uh and changeable
qualities
they cease to be what they they were a
moment ago they're just they're and they
when you're talking about emotional
states they cease to map back on to you
and your self-concept as meaningful in
the same way so that suddenly you know
the anxiety you feel let's say before
going out on stage to give a talk you
know a moment ago it was
it had psychological meaning it felt
like oh you know okay I'm anxious how do
I get rid of this you know why am I this
sort of person why you know should I
have taken a beta blocker you know this
is the the conversation you're having
with yourself the moment you just become
willing to feel it as the pure energy of
you know the physiology of of you know
of cortisol release
it ceases to have any meaning it just it
ceases to be a problem in that moment
because it is no more no more maps on to
the kind of person you are then
a feeling of indigestion or a pain in
your in your knee maps on to the kind of
person you are it's just it's it's just
sensation anyway but back to the main
point here which is that if you train
your attention in this way
to notice the particularities of of
sensory experience and emotional
experience like you're looking for the
atoms of experience you know
um
you get better and better at that and
certain things happen but one thing that
one thing that I really do do think
happens is there's a kind of frame rate
change in in the the data stream where
you really are just you're just noticing
much much more
um
all of that is a very interesting way of
training it's not what I tend to
recommend now it's a great preliminary
practice for what I do recommend because
it gives you it really teaches you the
difference between being lost and
thought and not it really teaches you
what mindfulness is but it tends to be
done you know by you know 99.9 percent
of of people
in a dualistic way which you're again
you're you're set up to think okay I'm
over here as the locus of attention
you know and and I'm continually getting
distracted by thought and the project is
to not do that anymore and actually pay
attention to the breath and sounds and
Sensations and and every time I get lost
in thought I'm going to go back here but
this whole dance of I'm lost in thought
now I'm now I'm strategically directing
my attention again
all of this seems to ramify this sense
of self the sense of of there's one to
be doing this there's somebody holding
the spotlight of attention and getting
better at coming back to the object of
meditation
um again it's inevitable that
99.9 of people are going to start there
and stay there for some considerable
period of time but the thing I like to
do when I talk about all of this is
undercut the false assumptions that are
anchoring all of that as early as
possible because where where I think you
want to be
is recognizing that
there is no place from which to aim
attention right there this whole
dualistic setup of subject and object is
the thing that is already not there and
it's not that you it's not that it's
there and you meditate it out of
existence successfully it's really not
there and if you if you learn how to
look for it you can see that it's not
there and feel that it's not there and
it no longer seems to be there right
it's like it's it's not and it becomes
like again like a bi-stable percept
where you looked at it long enough and
you thought okay now I see the vase and
the face and
um
I can't unsee it and every time I look
it's it's there again right and
um
so yeah I mean so to come back to the
the example you gave with your um your
colleague at Stanford
um
whose book I know I have I haven't read
it is this is the he wrote a book
projections right uh yeah
um uh so it's on my stack to read but um
it's the opposite what I'm recommending
essentially the opposite end of the
Continuum of the sort of internal
exercise he was he he was doing so
rather than so you know he's doing
something very deliberate and controlled
and he's you know he is deliberately
thinking in complete sentences and kind
of commandeering the you know the the
um the Machinery of thought and
attention uh in a way that I would
imagine I mean I'd be interested to talk
to him about it but I would imagine
it he really feels like he's doing that
right and there's he's an engineer you
know as you describe it in this way it
reminds me he he's he's a physician but
he's also an engineer so it's really
about taking the the raw materials of
thought and Engineering something
structured from it right um right you
know I haven't been in uh Carl's mind
um yeah but if we got him talking on
that I'm sure we would get a yes
we'll do that conversation at some point
but it's the exact opposite of what the
exact opposite would be to recognize
that
the sense of control is a total illusion
right there it could because you don't
know what you're going to think next
right and even he in the most laborious
way I mean he could he could just
get as muscular as he wants with it he
still doesn't know what he's going to
think next right thought because
thoughts simply arise right like you
know I mean you know you can run this
experiment for yourself and this
connects up to the topic of Free Will
which we might want to touch but
I mean just think of any category of
thing you know if I asked you to think
of you know the names of cities or of
you know friends you have or famous
people you you can you know remember
exist or think of nouns or you know you
know anything
um
and just watch what comes percolating
into Consciousness right now
there's
there are things you can't think of are
there things you don't know the name of
you know their languages you don't speak
there's there are famous people you've
never seen or never heard of right so
like like so you have no control over
that part like those those names and and
faces are not going to suddenly come
streaming into consciousness
but of of the the totality of facts and
figures and faces and names that you do
know right
only some will come Vine for inclusion
right and they're not and there's
there's a sort of you know I'm sure we
could
um
make guests and we know something about
the Neurology of this but you know
depending on what Channel your your um
you're waiting for thoughts in I mean
it's gonna be different if it's visual
or semantic or or um episodic memory I
mean all of these things are different
but
um
wherever you kind of Point your inner
gaze of attention and wait for the next
face or name
certain things are going to come and
certain or certain things aren't going
to come and how you land on one right
there'll be this process if you're
paying attention though you might think
let's say let's say we go with
names of cities right you just so you'll
you'll think of Paris You'll Think of
London You'll Think of Rome You'll Think
of Sedona so these these names will come
and if I ask you to just say one right
so just Minneapolis is what came to mind
for me it was very straightforward it
was Minneapolis the famous person was
Joe Strummer and they just like I can
give you reasons why I think they those
came to mind recent conversations okay
so so whatever so we know we know a fair
amount of a fair bit about much of this
so one we know that your reasons you
know obviously could be right or wrong
they're very likely to be wrong because
we have this sort of confabulatory
Storytelling mechanism even in an intact
brain where we just you know we we all
seem to never lack for the reasons why
something came to mind and we know we
can know we can manipulate people in
ways that prove that people are just
reliably wrong and confident you know
confidently so about the reasons why
they thought of things or did things but
leaving that aside even if you're
completely accurate right
um
there are there are people's names who
you know in cities names that you know
that inexplicably just didn't come to
mind and if we ran this experiment again
and again again they wouldn't come to
mind if your brain was in precisely the
state it was in a moment ago if we if we
could return your brain to the state it
was in a moment ago correcting for you
know all the deterministic changes and
all the random changes that would have
to you know be corrected for to just get
all the synapses and the synaptic waves
and you know everything in in the state
it was in to produce Joe Strummer in
Minneapolis right you're going to if we
rewind that movie that you know that
part of the movie of your life you're
going to say Joe Strummer in Minneapolis
a trillion times in a row right so this
is why
in my view the notion of Free Will makes
absolutely no sense right
um and you can add as much Randomness to
that process as you want it still
doesn't get you the freedom people think
they have
there's another conversation to have
about you know why none of that matters
and why things only get better once you
admit to yourself that Free Will is an
illusion uh and yes you can get in shape
and you can diet you can do all the
things you want to do and you don't have
to think about free will but
the from a from a
contemplative meditative point of view
the thing to notice is that everything
is just springing into view right you're
like there's no place from which you are
authoring your next thought because you
would have to think it before you think
it right like like there is just there
is just this
fundamental mystery at our backs that is
disgorging everything that we experience
and what if I'm speaking so if I'm
talking about something and I have some
command of that information I can often
sense what I'm going to say next and
then find myself saying it and hopefully
that's right and not something else I
certainly said things I didn't intend to
say or never thought I would say in life
but when engaged in speech or action
it at least gives us the illusion I
think that we somehow have more command
over our thoughts yeah well you have a
script I mean it's like there are things
you know a lot about and you've talked
you've talked about them a lot and you
you know you have the things you want to
say about those things and the things
you you don't want to say or you
wouldn't want to say
um and you know you can you know it
still is a bit of a high wire act
because you can misspeak or you can fail
to get to the end of a sentence in a
grammatically correct way and and it's
again all of this objectively this whole
process is mysterious to you right like
you you don't know how you follow the
rules of English grammar right like that
like your tongue is doing it somehow and
you know
um and when it fails it fails and you're
just as surprised as the next guy that
it failed and you know you mispronounce
a word and okay I don't know what
happened there but it's if it keeps
happening I'm going to worry I had a
stroke and you know if it stops I'm I'm
gonna you know I'm not gonna worry about
it uh so it's still mysterious even when
you're doing it in a very
um wrote deliberative and repetitive way
but when you're talking about something
you've talked about a lot and you know
you sort of know where you're going to
go right like and this is you know
we have many conversations like this
um
it is somewhat analogous to like a golf
swing where it's like you know how you
want to do it there's going to be all
kinds of errors that are going to creep
into your execution of it in in real
time but there's like you you basically
have a pattern and so you you have
certain linguistic patterns which you're
following
um again none of this is a proof of of
free will but I will grant you that you
know phenomenologically it feels
different than just waiting for the next
thought to come
but my point is is that even if you're
um I mean you can trim it down to the
simplest possible thing like you take
two things
you like to to drink
right you may you like you like coffee
and you like tea and you're deciding
which to have right both are on offer
you've got two cups in front of you and
and the question is you know which you
know or I hear I've got water and I've
got coffee which am I going to drink
next it's a it's incredibly it's as
simple as possible decision
and no matter how long I make this
decision process I could literally sit
for an hour trying to figure out which
to reach for next
and I could have my reasons why and I
could have my all myself talk
there's there's going to be a final
change in me that's going to be the
proximate cause of me deciding one over
the other and that no matter how
laborious I can make it seem in in terms
of my reasoning about it
um
it is going to be fundamentally
mysterious as to why I went with one
rather than the other right whatever
story I have like because it's like it's
it's still going to be as mysterious as
you thinking of Joe Strummer when you
absolutely like you know of the
existence of Marilyn Monroe just as much
and yet she simply didn't occur to you
right it's like it's fundamentally
mysterious like there are people who are
even more famous than Joe Strummer to
you right who who I mean I'm sure you
you know you he may be somebody who you
have thought a lot about but but
they're they're people who like if we
could just inventory you know your
conscious life going back the last 10
years they're people who you've thought
about more than Joe Strummer yet they
didn't appear right so and and that's
that is mysterious right and they could
have but they didn't and so
um
and what what I'm saying is that this
mystery never gets banished in our
experience whatever stories we have to
tell about it like because if if the
story is oh well I went for the water
because
um
I you know I I think I've been drinking
too much coffee you know I I I listened
to Andrew huberman's podcast and he was
saying talking about caffeine and I
think I probably good for us but you
don't want to overdo it yeah yeah okay
so let's say that is actually the causal
chain like I listened to your podcast
you said something about caffeine now
I'm now I'm self-conscious about my
coffee intake right but
that's just just adding a couple of
links to the chain there's there's still
this fundamental mystery of
well why did I find that persuasive and
why why did I find it persuasive now and
not five minutes ago when I was drinking
the coffee right like why did I just
remember it now or why was it effective
now like what like you could you only
have
your experience in every moment
is precisely what it is and not one bit
more like and and this subsumes even
moments of real resolve and effort and
you know picking yourself up by your
bootstraps and changing everything it's
like you're on a diet and you're tempted
to eat chocolate and you think you're
about to reach and say no I'm not I'm
not breaking this diet this diet is
actually going to stick right okay why
did that arise in that moment and not at
this analogous moment on your last diet
right and why did it arise now to
precisely the degree that it did why why
will it be
as effective as it will be and have the
half-life that it will have and not you
know 10 more or less like all of those
are always mysterious to you well could
we give a uh as we did before
um an evolutionary in a developmental
explanation an evolutionary explanation
might be that
um directed attention and action is
metabolically demanding it would be uh
inefficient or impossible for us to be
in constant you know deliberate action
and with access to all the relevant
information as to why we would do
anything so our idea is literally spring
to the surface
um at the last possible moment
um in order to offset uh the metabolic
the great metabolic requirements of
having ideas that are related to goal
directed action or that goal directed
action is expensive that's one idea the
other idea would be and we know this as
a fact which is that initially the brain
is fairly crudely wired that's not true
within the neural circuits that control
breathing uh heart rate Etc but within
the neural circuits of sensory
perception thought Etc they're fairly
crudely wired and then across
development
there's a progressive pruning back and
also in parallel to that a strengthening
of the connections that underlie
directed action and thought
um and here I don't mean directed as in
Free Will I mean just that can I can
decide to imagine an apple and imagine
that Apple for instance right um
there seems to be some maintenance of
the the random fine random wiring in
systems I mean we've seen this even in
in worms in flies in in you know in a
so-called lower uh invertebrates and
lower vertebrates and we see this in
humans and it seems to be uh that
there's a lot of background spontaneous
activity I mean I've sunk electrodes
into the brains of uh humans macaques
carnivores and mice and in every case
most of what you hear is called hash and
it has nothing to do with hashish is
just on the Audio Monitor which is
you're picking up a bunch of action
potentials right so you're listening to
a chorus of action potentials but it's
rare to find a neuron that Faithfully
fires to represent some sensory stimulus
in the world and you can arrange that
marriage experimentally so that you can
arrive at those strong signal to noise
events but I was always struck by how
much noise there is in the system all
around all the time and people argue as
the noise really noise Etc and is it you
know um there's still a lot debate about
that but I can imagine that some of this
uh the spontaneous nature of thoughts
just relates to the fact that there's a
lot of background spontaneous activity
in the brain now why that is is a whole
other discussion but um but if I were to
sort of set up two constraints that
there's a lot of spontaneous activity
it's going to Generate random thoughts
thankfully not much random action
although there's a little bit of random
action in our daily lives and then
against that say well any deliberate
thought or motion is going to be
expensive right it's a metabolically
expensive organ to begin with and so you
just have to Evolution has arrived at a
place where
um spontaneously geysering up of things
um upon which like deliberate thoughts
and action are superimposed is the best
arrangement overall for this very
metabolically demanding organ is that is
that a I mean what I basically gave was
just kind of a biological description of
of one just one narrow aspect of it but
can we get comfortable with that and the
reason I say get comfortable is that you
know I'm here I admittedly I'm forcing a
little bit of a striptease towards what
I think I and everyone else wants to
know which is how to meditate and why in
particular meditation convinces us that
something doesn't necessarily have to be
eliminated but that was actually never
there I feel like we're we're now set up
a sort of like almost like a I you're
not contradicting yourself by any means
but in my mind there's a contradiction
and here's the contradiction
[Music]
I love this statement that meditation
over time or done properly reveals to us
that we're actually not trying to make
the gap between actor and observer go
away it was actually never there to me
that's one of the more important
statements that I perhaps have ever
heard and it inspires me to go further
down this path of meditation because
I've never experienced that right um not
deliberately and certainly not through
meditation
if I ever experienced it it was
transient enough that I you know I'm
intrigued to to experience it more so on
the one hand you're telling me something
was never there and there's a profound
experience to be had by anyone that's
willing to do the work to arrive at that
experience of the loss of that illusion
on the other hand I'm hearing that
there's a
um a profound Gap that really does exist
which is that you know we we believe
that our thoughts are
um somehow from us
um and indeed they're from in in the
cranial Vault someplace maybe in the
body a bit as well
but that
we over uh attribute
the degree to which we are that and that
is us in a way that's volitional that we
control and so once I'm hearing that
there's something there's an illusion
that we can eliminate and on the other
hand I'm hearing that there's an
illusion that we can't eliminate and
maybe these are unrelated and I'm
bridging them in a in an unimportant way
that seems only important to me but
somehow I can't resolve these two and
maybe the thing to do then is is can we
separate them in terms of a practice to
witness them
that would allow us to resolve them
separately
right so yeah I think I I'm hearing the
problem there's this um
well let me kind of bracket the whole
Free Will discussion because it's it's
it really is the flip side of this coin
that that I'm uh you know the the
obverse of which is the illusion the
illusion of the self okay so at least I
might be on the right track yeah they
are the opposite sides of of according
okay great because to me they seem very
different in in essence no because
because what I'm calling the sense of
self
and what people what I think most people
feel as their core sense of self is the
this feeling of I mean it's the feeling
of being the locus of attention but it's
also the feeling of being the locus of
agency like I can do the next thing I I
like who's doing this who's reaching for
the cup I am right I I intended this and
now I'm doing the thing they might and
my intent my conscious intention is the
proximate cause of my reaching right
um so I'm the auth and so I'm the author
of my thoughts and actions essentially
and I'm and my and my specific uses of
attention right so I can I can pay
attention to the breath I get lost in
thought I come back to the breath but
um you know the law the the ins on some
level the thoughts themselves are more
of my doing something
uh with all with almost you know
authorial intent right like I'm thinking
like oh you know like what the hell is
this guy talking about I'm I know I'm
thinking you know I know you know who's
saying making these thoughts I am right
like that's that's the person who really
doesn't get what I'm saying is thinking
something like that right it's like what
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about like
I like I know I'm here I'm a self I'm
you know I'm I'm a body I'm a mind I can
reach for things that these are these
intentional actions are different from
things that happen to me right uh a
voluntary action is different from an
involuntary one you know so having a
Tremor is different from consciously
deciding to pick up a glass right
um
so obviously everything I'm saying about
meditation and the self and Free Will in
order to be a sane picture of a human
mind and of reality has to conserve the
data of experience such that yes I can
acknowledge the difference between a
Tremor and a a deliberative you know
voluntary motor action
um
and uh you know and the things you do
volitionally are different not just
psychologically and behaviorally but
they just have different implications
for like in a court of law you know you
accidentally hit someone with your car
or you did it on purpose that's still a
distinction that matters right it
importantly it tells us a lot about the
global properties of your mind such that
you know we have a sense of what you're
likely to do in the future if you're
someone who likes running over people
with your car you know you're a
psychopath who we need to worry about if
you're someone who did it by accident
well then you know you may be uh
culpable for for the level of negligence
that allow that to happen but you're a
very different person and we we treat
you differently and we we're wise to
um so anyway we can those let's bracket
all of that
um
there's this I mean there's some
fundamental there's there's some false
assumptions about
the underlying logic of this process
which I think it's worth addressing and
there's actually there's a kind of found
object in the news that I I talk about
at one point I forget where it is in in
the waking up app but there's a story
that I stumbled on on the internet
um I think it's about 12 or 13 years old
of a um a tourist bus in I think it was
Norway it was somewhere in
northern Europe
and I had about 30 people on it and one
person was a was described as an Asian
woman uh and they all they went to a
rest stop and everyone got off the bus
uh and they you know shopped and had
lunch and and this Asian woman changed
her clothing uh for whatever reason and
they all got back on the bus
um I think the relevance of it being an
Asian woman is that you know there were
language barriers that that explained
what later happened
um so everyone gets back on the bus the
Asian woman has changed her clothing and
the bus is about to leave but then
someone notices hey there's a there was
an Asian woman who got off the bus who
isn't it hasn't come back yet and they
tell the driver this
um and this poses a problem so now
everyone's waiting for this person to
return but in fact everyone was on the
bus that this woman had just changed her
clothing and was not recognized by her
fellow Travelers
so everyone gets concerned as this
tourist doesn't you know show up and
they start looking for her right and
they can't find her and so a search
party is formed and the Asian woman
because of the whatever language barrier
um
thought heard that there was a missing
tourist so she joins the search party
which in fact is looking for her right
and this goes on into the night and
they're ready in helicopters that you
know for a dawn patrol to find the
missing tourist
um now at some point along the way I
think it was at like three in the
morning
this tourist realizes that she is the
object of this search right and
obviously the whole thing unravels she
you know she confesses that she changed
her clothes and you know that the
problem is solved but the problem is not
solved
by the the logic that the Seeker is
expected right so it's like it's not
true to say that the missing tourist was
found in in the way that was expected
right because the missing tourist was
never lost the missing tourist was part
of the search party right and so when
you think about it from her point of
view like what happened she's part of
the search party she's looking for the
missing tourist not knowing that she in
fact is the missing tourist so what
happens at the moment she realizes
that everyone's looking for her right
like what what is it the the search
isn't consummated
in the way that is implied by the logic
of everyone's use of attention
um and yet the problem evaporates and
there's something deeply analogous about
the structure of that
and the the meditative Journey we in in
precisely in again not talking about all
the changes in the possible changes in
the contents of Consciousness that could
be good which again cut they come along
for the ride anyway when you when you
do the thing I'm talking about
it's not on this point of looking for
the self and not finding it and
there is this sense that okay the self
is here and it's a problem it is the the
string upon which all of my conscious
States mostly unhappy ones are strong
right it's the thing that is at the
center of my anxiety it's the it's it's
the it's the thing that I don't feel
good about it's a thing that one
criticized I sort of let implode
um it's the center of my problem and now
I'm trying to feel better and meditation
has been handed to me as a as a possible
you know remedy for my situation and it
and it's billed as a remedy in fact it's
it's it's I'm hearing from this guy that
this is the thing that is going to cause
me to realize that myself isn't where
you know or as I thought it was
um so now I'm going to look right and so
again you're you're the sense is I start
out far away from the goal here I start
out with a problem I'm now meditating on
the evidence of my unenlightenment right
I can feel my problem I feel that I'm
distracted and distractible and I feel
as this sort of cramp at the center of
my life whether it's me and I'm not as
happy as I want to be I'm not as
confident as I want to be I'm I'm more
distractible than I want to be and now
I'm paying attention to the breath right
um
this is what the search party feels like
this is what the the confused tourist
feels like in her own search party and
she's she's looking she's looking for
the missing person and so the the sort
of the the angle of of you know the
inclination of all of this
is and the logic of it is all wrong you
know understandably so uh given how we
we all get into this situation
but
you know it's useful to continually try
to under undercut it and
um
recognize that the thing that's being
looked for
is is actually right on the surface
which is you know the there is no one
looking there is no place from which you
are paying if you're paying attention to
the breath or to sounds or noticing the
next thought arise
this sense that you are over here doing
that thing
is actually what it's like to be
thinking and not knowing that you're
thinking you're not there's a there's a
thought there's an undercurrent of
thought that's going uninspected in that
moment and
um so there is just a there's a
continually looking for the mind looking
for the center of experience looking for
the one who is looking which again which
is the kind of the the orienting
practice here and there's a lot more I
say about this obviously
um over waking up but um
it's it's the experiment you have to
perform in order to get ready to
recognize that this whole the search
party you know was formed in in error
essentially and the the problem that
you're trying to to solve with this
practice does evaporate in in a similar
way which is like
you don't actually get there
in the way that you're hoping for right
it's like like you drop out the bottom
of this thing in an unexpected way it's
not um there's actually another kind of
a similar
Parable or or anecdote that I don't
remember if it's Zen or Sufi or I mean
I'm sure it's been reappropriated in
many different ways but or by many
different traditions
but there's a there's you know the the
case of somebody who's lost in a town
and they're asking for directions you
know you could put put this in in
Manhattan you could let's say you're
wandering Manhattan and you're you're a
tourist you don't know where anything is
and you stop and ask someone you know
where is Central Park
and the person thinks for a second they
says oh yeah unfortunately you can't get
to Central Park from here
right now that is a very strange I mean
we you think about that for a second you
realize okay that's a
that's an absurd claim there is no place
that you can't get to from the place
you're starting you know on Earth right
that's a failure to describe the
physical uh relationships between
anything in the world yeah that's just
not the world we live in right so but
it's a funny thing but on some level
that is true
of meditation it's like you can't get
there from here like but the sense of
you the sense of you as subject
isn't brought along to this thing you're
looking for right like you're like
you're
you know it's almost like
it's almost like you're you're making a
fist and you're trying to get to an open
hand
the fist doesn't get to take that
Journey as a fist right like you don't
the fist doesn't go along for the ride
the fist
comes apart right and and on some level
our subjectivity is a kind of an an
attentional fist you know it is a
contraction of energy again it's it's so
much bound up in thought for for
uh most of us most of the time that is
and again when when properly inspected
there's just this you know evaporation
of the starting point but there's not
this there's not this fulfillment of I'm
going to get this fist is going to just
gonna if I you know
if life gets good enough if I get
concentrated enough focused enough you
know if I austere enough if I renounce
enough if I desire less if I you know
you know enough with enough good and
intentions this fist is going to move
into some sort of sublime condition
right that's not
the logic of the the process I I really
appreciate these
um models and analogies for conscious
experience both as most people
experience them and harbor them and it's
as a way to frame what's possible
through a through a proper meditation
practice I do want to talk about what a
proper meditation practice looks like a
bit
but at some point
um
I do want to raise a model of maybe even
just perceptual awareness to see if it
survives the filters that you've
provided
um but first just even if briefly and
then we could return to it
you know what does this meditation
practice or set of practices look like
obviously uh the app is a wonderful tool
I've started using it as I mentioned in
the beginning my father's been using it
for a while and many people have Drive
great benefit from it but if we were to
break it down meditation into some basic
component parts
as we have broken down
um normal perceptual experience in some
of its component parts yeah
um I can just throw out some things that
I associate with meditation and maybe
you can elaborate on on how these may or
may not be applied for instance
um there is almost always
um a ceasing of motor robust motor
movement I know there are walking
meditations and so forth but it seems
like sitting or lying down and perhaps
not always but often limiting our visual
perception closing the eyes right
um directing a Mind's Eye someplace
um
is there a dedicated effort toward
generating imagery
what are the component parts and where
I'm really going with this is why would
those component parts eventually allow
for this disillusion of the Fist or the
um the realization that there is no
distinction between actor and observer
and so on yeah yeah well so to answer
that second question first
ultimately meditation
is not a practice that you're adding to
your life it's not it's not doing more
of anything it's actually ceasing to do
something it's ultimately
non-distraction I mean it's ultimately
you're recognizing what Consciousness is
like when you're no longer distracted by
the the automatic arising of of thought
it's not the thoughts don't arise it's
not that you can't use them it's not
that you've become irrational or or
um uh you know unintelligent I mean like
all of that you still have all of your
tools but
their every everything is in plain view
I mean there's an analogy in Tibetan
Buddhism which I love which is um
you know kind of in the final stage of
meditation uh thoughts are like thieves
entering an empty house you know there's
nothing for them to steal right so you
know in in the usual case thoughts are
there really is something in Jeopardy
every time a thought comes I'm not
meditating anymore and and not only that
I feel terrible because of what I'm
thinking about most of the time right
um and
so it's totally understandable the
thoughts seem like a problem in the
beginning and for certain types of
meditation they are explicitly thought
of as a problem because you're trying to
focus on one thing to the exclusion of
everything else including thought and
that is a kind of what I call
concentration practice earlier
and that is a you know it's a that's a
training that can be good to do it
becomes a tool that you can use for
other kinds of of insight but it's a
very specific and it's kind of brittle
skill in the end I mean it is it's a
skill just like I'm going to pay
attention to one thing and I'm going to
do that so well that everything else is
going to fade out and it's somewhat
analogous to what you you described in
the visual system if you if you you know
have a laser focus to one fixation Point
everything else in your visual field
begins to to fade out but
meditatively if you have a laser focus
on any one thing whether it's the breath
or or you know a candle flame whatever
it is
not only does I mean
let's use the breath for you know for a
second uh because your eyes are can be
closed
um
I mean you can lose all sense of
everything I mean you can lose all sense
of hearing and your physical body can
disappear I mean it like literally can
become incredibly subtle and vast and
drug-like
and many people approach meditation
thinking kind of climbing the ladder of
those changes into subtlety and vastness
that's the whole that's the whole game
right and
it can be a deeply rewarding game to
play and it also does come with all
kinds of ancillary benefits I mean all
the focus and the calm and the and the
the kind of smoothness of emotional
states I mean all that comes with
greater concentration and it can be
quite wonderful
um but again at best that's a tool to
aim in the direction that I'm talking
about now with with respect to
meditation which relates to more what I
would call you know mindfulness
generically
um and ultimately kind of non-dual
mindfulness so mindfulness generically
and for for most people
certainly in the in the beginning
dualistically is
just the practice of
paying careful attention to whatever is
arising on its own right now in the
beginning it's it's natural to take a
single object like the breath as a
starting point it's kind of an anchor uh
but you know very very quickly you know
over the course of even you know your
first week of doing this people you know
teachers and you know
um various sources of information will
recommend
that you know once you get some facility
once you know the difference between
being lost and thought and actually
paying attention to the breath well then
you can open it up to everything you can
open up the sounds and other Sensations
in the body and and moods and emotions
and even ultimately thoughts themselves
and so very quickly you can recognize
that
thoughts are not intrinsically the enemy
to this practice they are also just
spontaneous appearances in Consciousness
that can be observed
um but for some considerable period of
time people will feel that there is a
place from which that observation is
happening right there's just you know
I'm now the one who's being mindful
um
and however
attenuated that sense of self can be and
again it can it can get very expansive I
mean you can you know you can lose you
know as you get anything just a modicum
of concentration
you know it becomes very drug-like and
you get you know your the boundaries of
your body dissolve and your feeling of
having a body can disappear and
um and you you know if your eyes are
closed you know your visual field I mean
most people when they close their eyes
initially they just forget about their
visual field but you know it's if you
close your eyes right now you notice
your visual field is fully present
and you know it's you we call it dark
but it's not quite dark there is this
sort of scintillating uh some field of
of color and Shadow
um that's there in the darkness of your
closed eyes and
that can become a skylight domain of
kind of vast
uh uh you know visual expression that
opens up as you as you get more
concentrated with you know with your
eyes closed right so you're so you can
very much be aware of seeing with your
eyes closed in in a meditative practice
um
but from the point of view of
mindfulness
the logic is not to care about any of
the interesting changes and experience
that come as a result of practicing in
this way because what you're what the
the underlying goal is is to
be more and more equanimous with changes
so it's not to grasp at what's Pleasant
or interesting and not to push what's
unpleasant or or
you know boring or or you know or
otherwise not engaging in a way
um
what you want is just a kind of a
skylike mind that just allows everything
to appear and you're not clinging to
anything or or reacting to anything
could I ask you what your thoughts are
about the differences between nouns
adjectives and verbs in the context of
what we're talking about and you're
describing and the reason bring this up
is that as you know I know everything in
biology is a process you know we we
would never ever
say oh you know the perception of that
red line on a painting is um is a noun
right I mean it's an event in the visual
system you're you're abstracting some
understanding about that thing in the
outside world and I think it's very
useful in thinking about the brain
um and people will notice I notice I
excuse me actively avoid the use of the
word mind because I figure especially
with you sitting across from me that
I'll I'll step in it if I if I do but
the brain generates a series of
perceptions or what have you by through
processes not nouns and so when thinking
about biology I think of development is
a is a is an arc of processes aging is
an perception is an arcoprocity they
just exist on different time scales and
so a little bit of what I'm hearing is
that inside of an effective meditation
practice there's a little bit of a of a
um certainly non-judgment but discarding
of the the noun and the adjective uh
modes of language like red apple okay
it's a red apple but then
you sort of need to eliminate some other
adjectives about it it's a rotten apple
it's a you know ripe apple and instead
view the appearance and disappearance of
that apple as a it's just a thing a
process as opposed to an event and now
events could we could really get into
the language aspect of the that just
reveals how
um diminished languages to describe the
workings of the brain at some level
um
I don't know if any of this resonates
but it but it seems to me the goal or
one of the goals is to start to
understand the algorithm that is the
fleeting nature of perception but to not
focus on any one single perception and
then to not even focus on one single
algorithm but to at some level there's a
um what is revealed to the meditator
over time is some sort of macroscopic
principle about
um the way perceptions work at a deeper
level right that there's that there's
sort of a deeper principle there that
sits below our certainly our normal
everyday awareness but that in paying
attention to the mechanics of all this
stuff and not judging those mechanics
not naming those mechanics or just
naming them and let them pass by that
there's some action function some verb
is revealed and that maybe that verb
maybe the word to describe that verb is
mindfulness maybe mindfulness is is
really just a verb to describe that I
don't know
um but is there anything here or am I
create am I yeah no I don't know if I'm
creating just like useless straw or if
there's if there's actually a seed here
of something real but to me anytime I
want to understand something in biology
or psychology I try and um broaden the
time domain and think in terms of verbs
not nouns or adjectives yeah yeah yeah
no that that's very useful and that's
somewhat
adjacent to this distinction I'm making
between dualistic and non-dualistic ways
of experiencing the world so even
dualistically
everything is still a process right and
and we're misled by the the reification
that noun talk gives us so and this this
applies not just to something like
mindfulness but even to something like
the self right so the sense of self
is also a process I mean it's it's a
verb it's not it's a work we're selfing
more than we ourselves right and
um and they're you know I even even
appropriate uses of of of the term self
that don't go away even when you when
you recognize that the this the core
subject self is an illusion
there are states of self right where you
you can recognize in your life that you
inhabit very different modes of of being
depending on the context so like there
are moments where you just by walking
into a certain building
you suddenly transition into a different
state of self like like suddenly you
pass through a door
and now you're a customer in a store
right so we know what that customer
feeling is like you're now the person
who's getting the attention it's a very
kind of formalized type of attention
from the person who's running the store
and
you know or a restaurant you're a
customer in a restaurant right that's a
um I just I just remembered something
that's kind of funny
um that uh it was born of a mismatch of
of this so I'll come back to that in a
second
um but um so there are uh
uh so we go through you you can be a you
know you can be a student in the
presence of a teacher you can be a
parent in the presence of a son or a
daughter you can be a spouse in presence
in the presence of your spouse and all
of those
shadings of like the the the the the the
change in context
um really does
Usher in some fundamental psychological
changes in just the states of
Consciousness that are available to you
I mean and it's and some of this is
really I mean I'm sure we could
understand
a lot about this you know personally and
and you know generically but
it is pretty mysterious I mean like I
mean there are people who I know who I
you know I'm with them in a certain way
and like based on something I'm getting
off of them
like I can't be that I'm I'm
effortlessly one way with them and
there's no way I could be that way with
somebody else right like it's just I
don't know if it's pheromones or their
you know their facial it's just the way
they are their facial expression but I
mean they're people with whom I'm really
kind of effortlessly funny and they're
people with whom you know I couldn't
even it would never occur to me to be
funny no matter what happened you know
it's like and and I have like
long-standing relationships with with
these people you know so like it's just
very
um
you know all that's very mysterious but
anyway the the difference there is is
not in this core sense of
subject in relationship to all the
objects it's in kind of the S the states
of self and but and all of that is just
is very verby right like all this is a
this pattern of changes it's a pattern
of what's available and what's not
available the capacities that are you
know that are that come online or not um
in in those various contexts uh but no
the the memory just had which I hadn't
hadn't had in a long time
it was one of these these moments where
I realized the power of these shifts in
context for states of self so I once uh
I was a um a young man I think I was I
was uh probably
22 or so and single and like you're just
like trying to figure out how how you
how do you meet women and like how does
how does one get confident to do this
well and
um I um I walked into a restaurant and
a um a kind of a woman was walking
toward me you know
toward the front door of the restaurant
but she was walking toward me in a way
where I just by default assumed she was
the hostess in the restaurant uh but she
wasn't the host that she was just a a um
you know a someone who had just eaten
there I guess
um so I walked through and she comes out
and so there's a fundamental
misunderstanding in me that's set up by
literally just this change in
architecture and I and so I just said hi
to her in a way that I would I
presumably I would say hi to any Hostess
who was coming up to ask me whether
where I wanted to sit
um but what had actually happened is I
had said hi to a total stranger in a way
that I tended at that point never to say
hi to total strangers because I was shy
and you know it was just like
um but apparently I gave her like a 10
000 watt you know high of like all of
the confidence you would have if you if
you were that sort of person and it just
ushered in a complete like you know this
is so I went to my table and this woman
like came back into the restaurant like
gave me her phone number right which was
something that was just a completely
foreign experience to me you know and it
was based completely on my
misunderstanding of the situation I was
in right and and so anyway that among
the understanding uh among the
misunderstandings that one can have and
then
um action engage in life that was a
somewhat Adaptive One yeah you know but
but then you realize that okay but then
there are certain people who recognize
this Machinery to whatever degree or
have that kind of natural aptitudes for
bringing certain things online or not
such that
okay they can make these State they can
consciously make these states of self
you know this kind of this level of
gregariousness say available to them in
different in the circumstances where
it's actually useful to them so if you
if you're single and you want to meet
people well it's actually very helpful
to to feel confident enough to just go
say hi to strangers and ask them how
they're doing and and to be to be you
know online you know in in that way
where at that point in my life in that
circumstance
you know by how you know by default I
was going to ignore this stranger who I
was passing by in the doorway of a
restaurant but thinking she was the
hostess I was engaging her you know
fully
um so anyway you can consciously again
this does not invoke Free Will at all
but yes you can consciously decide to
play with this with these mechanisms
such that you can decide you what state
states of self
uh would be more normative to have you
know given what you want in life and and
you can become increasingly you know
attentive to the ways in which you get
played by the world you know you're a
kind of instrument your mind is a kind
of instrument your brain is a kind of
instrument
that is continually getting played by
the situations you're in and you can
become more of an intelligent curator of
your conscious States and your conscious
capacities just by noticing the changes
in you like I in graduate school is
something I talk about
I think at some point in waking up
this became very Stark for me because I
had
um
you know I was a you know an old
graduate student I had taken 11 years
off at Stanford between my sophomore and
junior year right so I like when I went
back to school talk about a leave of
yeah I know it was yeah yeah but so
Stanford had this you know you might
know this um they have the stop-out
policy where you never really drop out
you just stop asking you I can always go
back you don't have to write letters
saying that you still exist every you
know two years as you do in other
schools so
anyway I showed up after 11 years and
but you know so I was really on a
deadline and I felt late for everything
so I'm kind of you know finishing my
degree you know as quickly as I can
um as an undergraduate and then I jump
into graduate school and I'm an old
graduate student and I'm you know uh
there's a real sense of kind of urgency
like I'm late I should have done this
earlier I want to get this stuff done
um but then 9 11 happened and I asked
just as I had finished my coursework you
know getting my my PhD
um I was just getting into my research
but 9 11 intersected with my life in
such a way that I just had to drop
everything and write my first book and I
did that and then I just had to drop
everything and write my second book
because of the response to the first
book and so essentially I had like four
years where I was AWOL doing my PhD
but I still had a toe in the lab and I
was still showing up occasionally but I
was becoming this kind of cautionary
tale from the point of view of grad
school but I was also becoming kind of a
famous you know or semi-famous writer
because my first book had been a a New
York Times bestseller and I just I was
you know so I was getting some notoriety
as a writer
and so I was doing things like you know
I was giving a TED talk but I still
hadn't finished graduate school right so
like it was just it was some
I think that timing is right maybe I had
just finished graduate school when I get
the Ted talk but um
anyway so I I was in rolling in two
boats and one boat was sinking or you
know showing every sign of being damaged
and I was literally like you know
getting letters from the head of the
department saying you know like we're
concerned about you but on the other
hand I was like becoming a you know a
quasi celebrity in that world too
um you know at least in a world that was
overlapping so I was having the
experience of like going in I mean the
the moment where this crystallized with
for me in a in a fairly peculiar way was
I had a meeting at like three o'clock
with my advisor who was just this guy
Mark Cohen in the brain mapping Center
and at UCLA was a fantastic guy
um
great advisor uh I did not extract as
much wisdom from him as I should have
um brilliant scientist and
you know he's for him I'm late right at
least in my head like he's not that he
was riding me so hard but like in my
head I'm very self-conscious about how
I'm not living up to his expectations at
this point
um so I have a meeting with him at like
three o'clock and I'm just kind of
wilting you know under my you know you
know his gaze and my own imagined you
know inner gaze of his
um you know but that two hours later I
have a meeting with his boss you know a
dinner meeting with his boss who wants
to meet with me to get advice on
launching his book we have the same
publisher but I'm like the much bigger
author at you know Ed Norton you know
and he and he's he's coming to me for
advice
um
and so I'm ricocheting between two
diametrically opposites self-states that
are again this comes down to
architecture it's literally like the
state I was in walking into one building
and then leaving and walking into
another building on the same campus
um
and
they work completely opposite
self-concepts like in one in one context
I'm a [ __ ] up in another context I'm a
celebrity and you have Mastery and
virtuosity and yeah and and we're
developing it very quickly yeah and and
but so
again this is kind of a stark version of
that but everyone has some version of
this just in bouncing between talking to
their mom and then talking to their best
friend and then talking to a stranger
and then and talking to someone who's
who's very successful talking to someone
who's not very sick like all you notice
your vulnerability to all of this stuff
and ultimately
what you want is
a level of psychological Integrity that
that is truly divorceable from that now
I I'm not I'm not saying you're ever
going to get it perfect you know there's
always going to be some
I mean I I can't I can't talk about the
ultimate fulfillment of this process
like I'm not I'm not you know I'm not a
Buddha I'm not saying I've I've finished
the project but
um
I think there's
more and more you you know as you become
become sensitive to these changes and
you become sensitive to what it's like
to actually not be psychologically
reactive and not be definable
by your own self-concept your own idea
you're not identifying with anything
you're not hanging your hat on anything
you're not thinking about yourself in
terms in in in in in the kind of terms
that you would export to others and then
care about what they think about you
right like you're there's a kind of
invulnerability
uh that that arises that's not born of
being well defended it's born of of
being evaporated right it's like you're
no longer keeping score in those ways
once again we're at the I really
appreciate that description because I I
these days I'm I'm really intrigued by
um something we've known for a long time
that I'm you're certainly familiar with
is the prefrontal cortex's ability to
establish context-dependent rule sets
you know a Stroop task will be you know
basic example of you know reading
numbers or letters on cards and then
switching to having to report the colors
of the letters and numbers are written
in it's a basic task but brief on the
cortex obviously important for setting
context dependent thought and behavior
and directed action and and but within
the context of all these different
um variations of the self depending on
graduate school or you know relationship
where sitting alone in one's room yeah
there are different rule sets arise but
and somehow we are able to have a sense
a coherent sense of self that
encompasses all of those
um functional people can
um toggle between them as needed and not
overlap them inappropriately at least
not to the extent that it's um career
failing or life failing although
there are sad examples of that
um many of which exist in uh the Twitter
space I I know several colleagues not
directly of mine but people who
um through mistakes made with their
thumbs where they forgot context right
um or forgot to realize that the context
on social media is near infinite but the
context that existed in their head might
not be clear in the way that they
communicate something and they lost
their jobs right by saying what were
perceived as insensitive things in some
cases
were in fact offensive insensitive
things in some cases it's debatable
right
um
in any case I think that the the image
that now comes to mind relates to
something you've said several times that
um it's not about eliminating something
it's about revealing that something was
never actually there and then in terms
of sensory experience and this these
different aspects of the self I have
this image in my mind of
um I'm not an experienced scuba diver
but I've done enough of it you know I've
worn a wetsuit you wear a complete
wetsuit with the hood and this idea you
know if you were born into that wetsuit
you might think that yeah you you know
nudge up or lean up against a wall and
you experience it one way right and um
but were you to shed that wetsuit you go
wow there's this incredible landscape of
somatosensory experience that I had no
idea it goes Way Beyond levels of
sensitivity right now you're talking
about fine two-point discrimination and
light strokes and this could be positive
or negative pain in other ways too but
what you're describing is essentially
that the wetsuit was never really there
it but was created through a series of
in of action steps and what I think what
we're migrating towards here is out of
um for most non-intuitive
um or non-reflexive action steps that
reveal to us that in fact we're not
wearing this wetsuit now you raised one
um topic which I I think is analogous to
this wetsuit which is this notion of
distraction the normally distraction is
masking what would otherwise be a better
experience of life
um
I can think of distraction as falling
into two different bins one would be the
kind of distraction that is internally
generated like the fact that thoughts
arise and pull me down different
Alleyways and avenues of my of my brain
and my thoughts and my experience
and then the other would be
um and and that that would compete with
my ability to really focus on something
and then another form of distraction
which captures my ability to focus
intensely but has me focusing on the
wrong things and here I think the
Judgment of wrong is is reasonable to
include if for instance I'm being
impulsively yanked to something on
social media I'm being impulsively
yanked to someone else's pain and
experience and somehow confusing that
with my own experience this isn't
empathy but just getting yanked around
my attention as a spotlight is kind of
like over here over there I'm not
feeling as if I'm the one standing
behind that Spotlight controlling or I'm
not the spotlight right just to keep
with the what we've been building up
here so could you tell us a little bit
about distraction
and tell me whether or not
these two forms are in any way accurate
or inaccurate I'd be happy for them to
to be inaccurate and whether or not
there are other forms of distraction
that we need to be on the lookout for
and again
I think what most people are seeking is
what is the way to not just enhance our
ability to focus but to shed this
wetsuit like cloak that limits our
experience that I'm calling and that
you've called distraction
yeah I get like this I mean distraction
is is one component of it the other
aspect of it is identification with
thought and identification this is the
feeling of self is bound up in the sense
that that I'm the I'm The Thinker I'm
the one attending I'm the one vulnerable
on the inner kind of the inner
homunculus that's vulnerable to
experience
um
and like it can be gratified by it or
not and it's constantly trying to
improve it or and mitigate negative
aspects of it
um it's this it's the sense that there's
kind of a rider on the horse of
Consciousness as opposed to just
Consciousness and its contents so it's
again it rides atop this illusion of
control
um
Etc so
to go all the way back to the to the
question you asked about just
what isn't it you know what I recommend
as a starting point for for meditation
um
some of your assumptions are in fact
true yes it's it's uh you know I often
recommend in the beginning people close
their eyes and you you do a sitting
practice and that's different from a
walk-in practice and you can do both but
people tend to start you know sit in
with their eyes closed but again
ultimately where this is going is
it's not an artif meditation properly
recognized as not an artifice that you
add into your life it's not it's not
even a practice it is it is less rather
than more you know it and and therefore
it is also coincident with a you know
potentially every waking moment there's
nothing there's nothing that you can do
with your attention once you know how to
meditate that in principle excludes
meditation because meditation is just
a a recognition of an intrinsic
character of Consciousness in each
moment and all you have in each moment
is consciousness and it's contents
whatever you're doing so
um so in the beginning you you know
you'll be very deliberate and precious
about deciding to practice meditation
and you'll set aside 10 minutes in the
morning and you'll do that and then and
it'll seem very different from the next
10 minutes when you're you know spilling
out onto your to-do list and you're
trying to figure out you know what the
day looks like right but ultimately
you want to erase this boundary between
formal practice and the rest of life
such that there's it's just not remotely
findable and and
um
and that that's that's achievable and I
think even from the very beginning you
can relax this conceptual distinction
between meditation and its antithesis
because it's not
it's not at the level of anything you're
doing it's the level it's at the level
of
what's happening in your relationship to
thought you know like what what can you
notice when when you know like it's the
transition from
you know the by the by stable percept
you know you're looking at the at the um
the image and you see nothing now let's
say this you know the dalmatian you know
it's just the spots on the paper and you
just you don't see you don't see
anything and then all of a sudden the
dalmatian or the face of Jesus or
whatever the the images
pops out and then you see it it's the
transition from nothing to something
right that you the practice becomes the
transition from being lost in thought
and then waking up and Brit you know
it's very much like breaking the spell
of thought identification with thought
is very much like waking up from a dream
and having
it's like that that transition the whole
like you're having a dream
and
this
couple things are true there I mean it
it really is a kind of it's a it's a
psychosis that is just not we don't
problematize because you're safely in
bed and you're not moving unless you've
got some kind of you know sleep disorder
you're not walking around harming
yourself or anybody else so but to be in
bed
and to not know it and to think you're
you know running along a beach or you
know you're in you know getting tried
for murder in a court of law or whatever
the thing is that you're completely
delusional about right that is psychosis
right and it's like you're fundamentally
unaware of your circumstance and then
you the two things can happen there you
can either become Lucid within the dream
right which is interesting and that's a
whole there's a whole phenomenology of
that which
um can be practiced but more commonly
you can just wake up from the dream and
all of a sudden the problem you thought
you had is no longer there and and you
have a completely different context for
your conscious life like now you know
you're in bed you're safely in bed all
the while
there really is something analogous
when you break this identification with
thought right you're just you're having
a thought that seems to be some kind of
you know you know
uh
moral or psychological emergency
and and
yet
you can you can the moment you see
daylight around it the moment you see
that that the mind is larger than than
this mere appearance right then you have
it suddenly you have a degree of Freedom
that that a moment ago was just
Unthinkable right and you're also
you recognize you sort of come to in a
way you recognize your circumstance in a
way that you weren't a moment ago when
you were just talking to yourself when
you were just identical to that
conversation
um so this is all all to say that that
ultimately meditation
I mean so again there's another apparent
Paradox here many people don't know much
about meditation we'll say things like
you know well you know for me running is
my meditation or skiing or rock climbing
or playing the guitar or something they
like to do that gives them an experience
of flow
that's what that's what they go to to
feel better and that's that's the
opposite of all the you know the chaos
of their lives or the you know their
time on Twitter or whatever it is
in virtually every case it's it's not
true to say that that is effectively
meditation you're not gonna by learning
to play the guitar you're not going to
learn what I'm calling meditation and
you're not going to learn it by you know
cycling or getting getting no matter how
good you get at any of those things
you're not going to learn it by doing
those things but paradoxically
I mean not really but it can seem like a
paradox once you know how to meditate
then you can meditate doing all of those
things right meditation is totally
compatible with playing the guitar or
skiing or you know doing any ordinary
thing you like to do right so once you
know how to meditate and again it's
totally natural in the beginning to
formalize it and to set aside time each
day to do it because it is a it is a
training I mean it is something that in
the beginning you have to get used to
but once you have once you're getting
used to it
then there is no good reason not to be
experiencing this thing I'm calling
meditation this this insight into the
the
the
centerlessness of Consciousness the the
non-selfhood of Consciousness
um
you should experience it when you're
playing your favorite sport or when
you're having a conversation with
somebody and
then the reason then to come back to
your initial assumption about eyes
closed
a lot of practice even formal practice
can be done eyes open and it's important
to do it as open because so much of our
anchoring of our sense of self is is
based on visual cues I mean like we just
we we know that you can if you give
people the right visual cues you can
translocate their sense of self you can
give them an out of body experience you
know with a with a video display where
you can literally make them feel like
you go there's a body swapping illusion
you can make them you can make them feel
that they're in another person's body
looking back at their body if you if you
you know run the cameras the right way
I've done this in VR seeing an image of
of you they created an avatar for you
and then you're bodily movements
generate the movements of the Avatar and
um you start gaining presence as they
call it in the AR lingo very quickly and
then pretty soon
um you lose sense of your own bodily
representation and yeah and um it's a
little Eerie uh what's eeriest to me is
I'm going back into
you of course never left but um back
into your actual body when the VR
goggles pop off the world seems almost
overwhelming the number of sensory
stimuli that are in a like a laboratory
room which is actually quite sparse
right um so exactly what you described
this translocation of of Notions of self
through Visual experience and but
conversely when you lose the sense of
self the the sense of the self I'm
talking about
it can be especially Vivid and Salient
with eyes open because because so much
so many of your reference points to
selfhood are delivered visually right
especially in a social situation it's
like you know I'm talking to you you're
looking back at me right so your the
implication of your gaze is that I'm
over here behind my face implicated by
your gaze like so the sense that you're
looking at something is the sense of
self in that social context right and so
and if you're if your facial expression
changes like I'm saying something and if
you kind of furrow your brow like well
what the hell is it you know and I can
read into that facial change some inner
state of yours that is you know sailing
into me all of a sudden we've got this
sort of dance of like I'm noticing you
reacting to me and I'm that's that's
changing the way I'm feeling about what
I'm
that that that's that's the you know the
the purview of you know every Neurosis
everyone didn't want right and every
relationship I had a girlfriend when I
was a postdoc who's a who was um very
very uh she was brilliant really um
still is and she always said that every
relationship is is they're four arrows
used to say she's a neuroscientist still
is and said you know there's the arrow
of you know uh she was talking to me so
she said you know me to you and kind of
what you perceive coming from me and
then there's you to me and then there's
an arrow from the middle going right
back at each one of us right which is
our own perception of what the other
person is thinking about us and it's
feeding back on the other arrow and she
gave me this very
um clear but
um model of basically relationships um
uh the relationship failed but it was
good while it lasted I should say and
um but the four arrow model of
relationships actually shows up in every
type of uh one one-on-one relationship
and it's probably an under description
of the total number of arrows but is I
think it's exactly what you're
describing is that perception of self
Through The Eyes of other whether or not
we're empathic or not strongly shapes
the way that we access different context
dependent rule sets about what we're
going to say and not going to say it's
very Dynamic right yeah so but the
freedom
that I think we want and and people can
sometimes experience this just
haphazardly but the the thing that the
center of the bullseye from the
meditative point of view is to get off
that ride entirely and to because so so
that losing the sense of self in this
context of a social encounter
is to is to give up your face
essentially like you're like so and and
what what that
entails is or what that gives you is the
free attention to actually just pay
attention to the other person right and
the other person is now no longer quite
an object in the world for you there's
really just a kind of a totality of
which that person is apart
um
and and actually you know Martin buber
the the uh kind of mystical uh Jewish
philosopher uh talked about the kind of
the eye thou relationship and and this I
think is you know it's been a long time
since I've read boober but
um and I don't know if he goes you know
far enough to be truly non-dualistic but
this distinction between I I am now
um because the thou part of it is is I
think potentially this or again it's
been several decades since I read read
him but
there's a there's a there's a way of
beholding another person
where you have the free attention to
Simply behold them right like you're no
longer you're no you no longer care what
they think about you you don't feel
neurotically implicated by their gaze
you don't feel you you're simply the
space in which they're appearing right
and so you're free you're like like
there's just there's no and people can
feel and so you're you're
that you by definition you are no longer
self-conscious right and when this
phrase self-consciousness really does
get at
this what I'm calling the self the the
illusory self as a kind of contraction
and and you can you can notice this for
yourself just imagine what it's like
to go from not being self-conscious
to suddenly being self-conscious and the
the the the proximate cause of this you
know
almost invariably is suddenly
recognizing that somebody's looking at
you it's like you're in a Starbucks and
you're you know you're alone and you're
reading the newspaper whatever it is and
this is it now sounds highly
anachronistic it's been three years
since I've held a physical newspaper I
think in a Starbucks
um but you know you're you're just
minding your own business and you look
up and you just you're seeing you know a
room full of strangers
but then you notice that someone is just
looking at you you know and so like that
moment of eye contact right suddenly
that throws you back on yourself as a
kind of suddenly you're the object in in
the world for that other person that
recognition is
a the tightening there the kind of
contraction there is a is a
a
further ramification of this this
feeling most of us have most of the time
of being the center of experience like
that the place you feel like it's it's
like you know we're all walking around
with a fist and in moments of
self-consciousness the fist gets really
tight you know and that's and that's um
that's the thing that gets fully relaxed
when you discover this this what I'm you
know at various points called the nature
of mind or the the non-dual nature of
Consciousness it's just that there is no
Center to this experience and when you
recognize no Center then even when your
gaze is aimed at another person's gaze
there is no implication going back to
the center because there is no center
right and and rather than that being an
experience of
weird Detachment or confusion or or it's
it's actually an experience of Greater
relationship because you're no longer
you no longer defend it you're not
you're not defending anything over here
like you're not you're not braced
against anything you're just the space
in which that person is showing up and
so it's it's a it's a
an experience of being much more
comfortable
in in the presence of another person
well you know whatever your relationship
because you're not Contracting right and
then when you do when you have that
again and this is meditation right this
is meditation that is totally compatible
with having a conversation with somebody
and then when you notice yourself
Contracting like when you notice you're
not doing you're not meditating anymore
you're just you're actually reacting
like they just said something or looked
a certain way and now you're cast back
upon yourself
in relationship to them
that becomes a kind of mindfulness alarm
right then you know that that it becomes
like the the the
unsatisfactoriness of that
psychologically becomes more and more
Salient right and it's um
because that's not one that's not the
way you want to be I mean it's like it's
antithesis of it being as as comfortable
as you were a moment ago
but two
it's it's something you're doing
unnecessarily right like it's like
you're you're you're like again you're
making a fist when you don't have to
make a fist right and and it's
um again you can leave aside all those
circumstances where it's appropriate to
react to someone and you know I'm I'm
sure you know I'm into martial arts and
self-defense and yes you're not supposed
to be just this puddle of goo out in the
world who can be just mistreated by
people and and you know never put up you
know resistance but it's um
psychologically
you know even if
even if a state like anger or
contraction is sometimes normative and
appropriate the question is how long is
it normative and appropriate for like
how how long do you want to stay angry
for
um in my experience
these is kind of classically negative
emotions like anger and fear
are appropriate as salience cues you
know they Orient you to you know an
emergency or a potential emergency but
then in dealing with the emergency
they're almost never the state you want
to be in you know it's like you don't
you know you you don't like it's it's
better to actually be calm in an
emergency you know so oh absolutely I
think that
um and again the language is is
insufficient to describe what
um what you're telling us but I think uh
what comes to mind for me is this a
distinction between situational
awareness and self-awareness and we need
both but under conditions of uh
emergency true emergency
um or motivated desire we need to
um dial down the amount of
self-awareness in order to be more
effective within the situational
awareness
um but you said something very important
and my lab has been working on fear-like
States for a long time so I'm gonna I
confess I'm gonna um Rob this from you
but I'll credit you every time I
describe is that that the that the the
fear of the threat detection state or
set of events uh acts as a as a flag but
is not meant to persist in the way that
uh the flag went up right if one is to
be in their most adaptive State actually
Jocko willink and I were talking about
this he talks a lot about Detachment and
open gaze things that my lab is
interested in visual system and
autonomic interaction so why broadening
the gays literally broadens the time
domain of thinking you've come up with
new solutions to complex problems in
real time and so on and
um and you're describing an everyday set
of interactions where that could be very
useful and yet there seems to be
something that about the way you
describe meditation and what you've
managed to arrive at and what
practitioners of meditation can arrive
at which is something more than that
like it's not just about being effective
or optimizing all the language we see
thrown around a lot in the space that I
I live in these days but
um but something fundamentally more
important about how to experience life
and the self this
this realization that what you thought
was there was never really there there
but that there are constraints that
limit that and so to try and Fracture
those just constraints one by one would
you say that meditation as a practice
done for a few minutes each day or with
the app that it's a um kind of a step
function is a very non-linear in terms
of people's progress
um you know
I'm certainly going to go start doing
more meditation based on this discussion
truly um because anytime someone
describes a
um that there's
kind of a myth that we've been living in
I I become obsessed with the idea of
dissolving that myth that's a very
seductive phrase so thank you for using
that one there is no better marketing
tool which is I realize what you're not
trying to do here but that's for me to
capture my my um efforts you tell me
that there's a myth that I'm living in
and that it can be dissolved and that
opens up a better landscape
um yeah what is the the process like is
do some people make progress very
quickly do some people
um experience kind of Step functions
towards progress what is the
meditation practice look like over time
do you still meditate or do have you
just threaded it through your Jiu Jitsu
you're writing your daily life your
coffee your time with your wife Etc
yeah also just to come back to just to
to talk about the myth for a second so
they're really what you just enunciated
was a kind of a second doorway into this
whole project so like the the usual door
is through
the door of suffering for lack of a
better word I mean people feel unhappy
in a variety of ways and they get more
sensitized to the mechanics of their own
unhappiness and meditation is one of the
things on the menu the scene that is
explicitly built as a remedy for for
unhappiness and
uh and it is and that's you know I think
that's probably the most common path to
this but another path is just
intellectual interest I mean just
wanting to know what's real so about the
mind subjectively in a first-person way
and and there's there's no contradiction
between those two things I'm motivated
by both of them but
um
you know it's a totally valid doorway
into this
um
there are definitely step functions I
mean I would say they're there are at
least two I mean the and it really
really articulated along the lines of of
um
the framework I've been describing of
dualistic and non-dualistic mindfulness
right so in the beginning you're going
to start out you know 99.9 people will
start out dualistically paying attention
and and noticing the difference between
being distracted by thought and then
being on the object of attention whether
it's the breath or sounds or whatever
and eventually that you know that opens
up to all possible objects of attention
including thoughts and the and there's
still this fluctuation between being
distracted and then being mindful of
whatever
and the fact that it's open to all
possible objects differentiates this
type of practice from anything that is
narrowly focused on one object like a
mantra or a visualization or Society you
know those are other Paths of practice
that are more concentration based
um and interesting but
the the benefit of mindfulness is that
very quickly you realize this by
definition compatible with all possible
experience because you're not
artificially Contracting your attention
down to something you're you're just
being aware of the next thing a sight a
sound a taste a thought
um so
the first step function is to very
clearly experience the difference
between being lost in thought and being
clearly aware of any part of experience
including thought and to notice
the freedom the comparative
psychological Freedom that gives you
right so you can like your something's
made you angry and now you're thinking
about all the reasons why you should be
angry and have every right to be angry
and what you're going to tell that
person when you see them and
and then you notice you're thinking
right and you notice the connection
between the thought and the anger right
you like like the the minute spent lost
in thought about what's making you angry
is the thing that dragged through the
physiology of anger right and the moment
you notice that once you're mindful once
you can be mindful you can notice
thought as thought and how quickly that
dissipates that's just the language and
the imagery it just you couldn't hold on
to it if you wanted to and then you
noticed the physiology of the anger is
just this kind of meaningless
uh you know kind of inner incandescence
that has its own Half-Life and degrades
very very quickly when you're no longer
thinking about the reasons why you
should be angry you can't hold on to the
anger the anger itself dissipates right
and from from the point of view of the
one who's being mindful
this is tremendous relief I mean and at
minimum it's a degree of Freedom you can
at that point decide well how long do I
want to be angry for right is it useful
to stay angry don't want to be angry for
one minute two minutes five minutes ten
minutes or because before you have that
capacity to be mindful
you're going to helplessly be as angry
as you're going to be for as long as
you're going to be that way just based
on the kind of the time course if you're
thinking about it brooding about it
telling your wife about it you know like
just the you know it's just going to be
this conversation based misadventure in
you know negative states of mind
uh and you are you are going to be the
hostage of that for as long as you'll be
the hostage of that you'll have nothing
you can do apart from just deciding to
you know check out and watch Game of
Thrones again for the third time right
like like it's just you can divert your
attention to something else which is all
you know sometimes a good thing to do
but mindfulness even dualistic
mindfulness gives you this capacity to
just observe the mechanics of this and
then get off the ride when you when you
whenever you want
so that really is a step function like
first there was a time when there was a
time before you could do that and then
there's a time after which you can do
that
the other step function is
noticing that there is no one who is
doing that I mean this is the
non-duality the selflessness the the
centerlessness of awareness right the
fact that there's no place from which
the mindfulness is being aimed but the
fact that there's just this open
condition in which everything is
appearing you know thoughts included
to to have you as at that point
your mindfulness no longer becomes
it's no longer this
this dualistic effort to strategically
pay attention to anything as opposed to
being lost in thought
it's just what's left when thoughts when
when when the present recognized thought
unravels even before it unravels what's
recognized is
you are simply identical to the
condition in which everything is
appearing again this is not a I'm not
making a
a Deepak chopra-like metaphysical Claim
about the mind you know this is not I'm
not saying the mind isn't what the brain
is doing I'm not saying that you're
recognizing the Consciousness that gave
birth to the universe not making any
broad claims about metaphysics I'm just
talking about as a matter of experience
there is just this condition in which
everything is appearing right and what
you're calling your body again is a
matter of experience I'm not saying that
we can't have third person conversations
about you know physical bodies in the
physical world but as a matter of
experience the only body you're ever
going to directly encounter as your own
is an appearance in Consciousness right
so Consciousness is not in your body
what you're calling your body is in
Consciousness visually proprioceptively
it's like everything is just appearing
in this condition and
again you're not aiming that you're not
this is not a spotlight that you're
aiming at the body or at you know
there's just this condition in which
everything including anything you could
call yourself is appearing and
um
so yeah so that's the second step
function is to recognize that
this is all this is already true the
Consciousness is already without this
thing you've been calling your ego
hoping and you know hoping to to unravel
it through meditation
Consciousness is not going to get any
more selfless any more centerless any
Freer than it all always already is
recognized as such and so that's that's
the the step function at that point is
your mindfulness at that point the thing
you come back to when you're no longer
distracted is that that recognition
again and again and then it becomes yeah
it becomes compatible with anything you
would do and so to answer your question
yes I still practice you know formally
you know sometimes you know frequently
but not you know I definitely miss days
and I don't do it for I mean I you know
I I don't rule out the possibility that
I will go back on retreat at various
times just to you know check in with
that and see if that makes a difference
but
um
you know I tell you know I tend to sit
for um I may attended I've designed my
life
so that I can spend a lot of time
meditating without having to be formally
meditating like so you know you know
I'll go for a hike for two hours right
and what I'm doing when i'm hiking is
identical to what I'm doing when i'm
quote meditating you know sitting in a
chair you know doing nothing but
meditate
um
so it's um yeah I mean I just again the
I'm very um
I'm very interested in erasing the
boundary between what people are calling
meditation and the rest of life and that
so that's in in teaching these things I
tend to emphasize that from the
beginning because I think it's it's very
easy to
set up
um
to get to get gold by a bunch of
assumptions that cut that caused you to
be very um
split in your sense of what your life is
about and like I'm sort of banking my
meditation over here because I'm not
meditating two hours a day diligently
and you know this is going to be really
good for me and then over here is the
rest of my life
which is not nearly as wise or as useful
or as like this is the stuff that is
still the area of my problems and um
I think it's useful to recognize you've
got one you've got one life you know and
you've got this this
single condition of Consciousness and
his contents in every mode of life and
there's something to recognize about it
and you're always free to recognize that
you know you're truly even in your
dreams right I mean it's just not this
it never stops so
that's that's what I tend to emphasize
so earlier you told us that meditation
is not about changing the content of
conscious experience and in a different
podcast that you were on I heard you say
something to the effect of
that normally we are in our daily
experience and unless we are trained in
meditation
um unless we've dissolved this illusion
of the gap between uh actor and self and
observer
that
we require certain sensory events to
create collisions
within us and with the natural world
that sort of you know blast us into a
different mode of being
I want to use that as a way to frame up
this idea that some things such as
psychedelics but also a very long hike a
very long fast
um you know who knows a banquet uh you
know different types of Life Experiences
do exactly the opposite of what you're
describing meditation does which is that
they actively change the content of our
conscious experience
so much so that we often remember those
for the rest of our lives
could you tell us why psychedelics
can be useful and here I'll give the
caveats that maybe you'll feel
um obligated to give as well but this
we're talking about you safely and
responsibly age-appropriate context
appropriate ideally with some clinical
or other type of guidance legality
issues obeyed Etc all that stated
it was psychedelics to me are an
experience of altered perception
internal and external perception altered
space-time relationship somewhat
dreamlike I think it was Alan Hobson at
Harvard for a long time talked about the
relationship between psychedelic-like
states and dreamlike States
um because of this Distortion of
space-time dimensionality
um and
I haven't uh experimented with them much
I've been part of a clinical trial three
doses of MDMA which certainly altered my
the the quality of my conscious
experience in ways that led to a lot of
lasting and at least for me valuable
learning yeah so what are your what are
your thoughts about psychedelics in
terms of how they intersect with the
discussion that we've been having
and what utility do they play and
recognition of the self or in other
sorts of brain changes
well so uh yeah okay let's just price in
all those caveats that people can
anticipate
um
these drugs are not without their risks
and it's it's one problem is that we
have
this single term drugs or psychedelics
which names many different types of
substances and they're not all the same
and they're not so like MDMA is not even
technically a psychedelic I think it has
an immense therapeutic value and it
actually was my gateway drug to this
this
whole
area of concern amphetamine pathogen
right it's a sort of an amphetamine and
a pathogen yeah yeah I mean it's often
called pathogens yeah and a pathogens
yeah not pathogen M pathogen yeah and a
pathogen or an antactogen it's it's been
called
um but it doesn't tend to change
perception in the way that classic
psychedelics do and it's it's also
serotonergic but it's it's not
um
uh it has to be in some part differently
so than me even LSD and psilocybin which
are much more similar in classic
psychedelics both are also serotonergic
but they're not merely so and they're
they're also different
um and the higher dose you take of these
drugs the more you at lower doses
everything can kind of seem the same at
higher doses they they
they begin to diverge
and we can talk about the the
pharmacology if you wanted to but
um
the uh
I would just say that for many of us I
mean certainly for me psychedelics were
indispensable in the beginning in
proving to me that this was
the the the the first person
interrogation of the Mind was worth
doing you know because I was somebody
who at you know age
17 or 18 before I had any real
experience with um
with MDMA or LSD or psilocybin
um
if you had taught me how to meditate at
that point I think I would have just
bounced off the whole project I think my
mind was I I was just
I was so
cerebral in my just my engagement with
anything I was so skeptical of
any of the the spiritual the religious
and spiritual Traditions that that have
given us most of our meditation talk you
know
um
that I think I just would have
um I I know many of these people like I
you know I have I have tried to teach
you know Richard Dawkins to meditate and
Daniel Dennett to meditative I've
ambushed them with meditation and very
you know both both in a group setting
and one-on-one uh not not Dan but uh but
Richard I I ambushed on my own podcast
with a guided meditation
and
he just you know
from his he you know he closes his eyes
he looks inside and there's nothing of
interest to see right like it's just
it's like it's not he doesn't have the
the um
the conceptual interest in him that
would that would cause him to to persist
long enough to find out that there's a
there there right now
this is not a problem with LSD or
psilocybender MDMA and I know that if I
gave him 100 micrograms of LSD or five
grams of of mushrooms or you know 20 25
milligrams of psilocybin
um
that's probably not the analogous dosage
to the five grams of mushrooms five
grams of mushrooms would be more than
that
um
uh I forget what it is of uh of MDMA
maybe 120 milligrams I think the maps
doses uh which is the one that's under
clinical trials is 125 milligrams with
an option of a 75 milligram booster
right right funny I will remember
the facts that come to hands
um but uh
there's not there's just no possibility
that nothing's going to happen right now
something with with a psychedelic with
MDMA most people tend to have certainly
under any kind of guidance tend to have
a very uh positive you know pro-social
experience
um
but you know with a psychedelic you
might have a a a
somewhat you know terrifying experience
if you have quote a bad trip you know
and I've certainly had those experiences
on on LSD and and to some degree in
psilocybin but
um
the prospect that nothing is going to
happen is just
in you know a million you know nearly a
million cases out of a million just not
in the cards I mean just just
neurophysiologically something's going
to happen with the requisite dose of of
one of these drugs
and if if that thing that happens is
is psychologically at all normative and
you know Pleasant and interesting and
valuable which it is so much of the time
and certainly under the appropriate you
know set and setting and and guidance
um it can be you know a lot of the time
for
you know virtually everybody again there
are caveats if you if you're prone if
you think you have you know a proclivity
for schizophrenia or you know bipolar
disorder
this is almost certainly not for you you
know and anyone doing a the the studies
at like Johns Hopkins for for um
the therapeutic effects of of any of
these drugs they're they're ruling out
people with you know first degree
relatives with with any of these
clinical conditions
um
but so for somebody like me at 18
who didn't know that this was an area of
of not only interest but would it be
that you know the the center of gravity
for the rest of his life if only he
could pay attention clearly enough to
see that it could be right
um I was someone who very likely again I
don't know I don't have the counter
factual in hand I don't know what would
have happened if if someone had you know
forced me to meditate for an hour at
that point but
I know I wasn't interested in it until I
took MDMA
um
I know I wasn't having these kinds of
experiences spontaneously that get that
showed me that there was an inner
landscape that was worth exploring
um I was a very hard-headed skeptic who
was very interested in lots of things
but there was no alternative to me just
thinking more about those things right I
mean the idea that there's some other
way of grasping cognitively at the
interest in parts of the world
Beyond thinking about the world right I
just that just wouldn't have computed
for me at all right and if you had so I
just I and I literally I had no one ever
gave me a book to read or an ever had I
don't if you the noun meditation very
likely meant absolutely nothing to me
before before I uh took my first dose of
in this case it was MDMA
um so what the drug experience did for
me is it just proved yeah so the the
limit one of the limitations of a drug
is that you know obviously no matter how
good the experience the drug wears off
and then you're back to you know more in
more or less your usual form
and now you have a memory of the
experience and it can be a fairly dim
memory I mean some of these experiences
are so discontinuous with normal waking
consciousness
that it can be like trying to remember a
dream you know that just disappeared
that it degrades you know over the
course of seconds and then it could have
been the most intense dream you've ever
had and for whatever reason you can
barely get a purchase on you know what
it was about and
um
you know there's some psychedelic
experiences that are analogous to that
but
for most people most of the time there's
a residue of this experience and with
something like MDMA they can be quite a
quite Vivid
um
where you recognize okay there there was
a way of being that is quite different
than what I'm tending to access by
default and it is different in
in
ways that are just uh
you know obviously better and and
psychologically more healthy I mean it's
possible to be healthy psychologically
in a way that I I never imagined right
and that then when you be then when you
link it up to the traditional literature
around any of this stuff again so much
of it is
shot through with with Superstition and
other worldliness of of religion and you
know as as you know and I think you're
you're listening listeners probably know
I've spent a lot of time criticizing all
that but there is a baby in the bath
water to all of that right it's like
it's it's not that
somebody like Jesus or the Buddha or any
of the matriarchs and Patriarchs of the
world's religions it's not that they are
we're all conscious frauds or you know
temporal lobe epileptics or like there's
there's a there's a pathological lens
that you can put on top of all that but
once you have one of these experiences
on psychedelics or on a drug like MDMA
you know that there's a there there you
know that unconditional love is is a
possibility right you know that that
feeling truly one with nature right I
mean just so one with nature that you're
you could spend 10 hours in front of a
tree and find that to be the most
rewarding experience of your of your
life right that's a possible State of
Consciousness now it may not be the
State of Consciousness you want all the
time you know you don't want to be the
crazy guy by the tree you know who can't
have a conversation about anything else
but
uh once you have one of these
experiences you recognize okay there's
there's some reason why I'm not having
the beatific Vision right now and I
can't even figure out how to aim my
attention so as to have anything like it
and that's a problem right because it's
it's available right and it's it's the
best you know it is
among the best things that has ever
happened to me right and now I'm gonna
just only dimly remember what that was
like
um so how do I get back there on some
level and that's so that invites again a
logic of changes a logic of seeking
changes in the contents of consciousness
which set someone up for this this um
protracted or seemingly protracted and
and you know fairly frustrating search
to you know game their nervous system so
as to have those kinds of experiences
more and more
um and again it's not that that's in
principle fruitless
but it is from the point of view of the
kind of the core Insight of you know the
core wisdom of you know what I would
take from a tradition like Buddhism
which is not you know it's not the only
tradition that has given voice to this
but it I would argue it's given it you
voice to it the most in the most
articulate way
um
again leaving aside any of the
Superstition and and other worldliness
and miracles that you know we don't have
to talk about at the moment and you
certainly don't need to endorse in order
to be interested in this stuff
um
and so that's the the bifurcation
between
the all of the utility of psychedelics
and what I'm talking about
under the rubric of meditation is at
this point of okay once you realize
there's a there there what do you do and
what's the logic by which you're led to
do it and it's possible like if if your
only framework is
the good experiences the good feels you
had on on whatever drug it was
and
a a further discussion of of like what
that path of changes you know can look
like and that can become in a religious
context it can come in just a purely
psychedelic context or you know some
combination of the two
um
I think you can be misled
to a you can just be you can be misled
to just seek lots of peak experiences
you're just trying to string together a
lot of peak experiences hoping they're
going to change you every one of which
by by definition is going to be
impermanent right I mean it's it's first
it wasn't there then it's there and then
it's no longer there and then you've got
a memory of it right the ques what I
think it's what everyone really wants
whether they know it or not and their
right to want is
a type of Freedom that is compatible
with even ordinary States Of
Consciousness which which can ride along
with them into extraordinary States Of
Consciousness I mean so what I hadn't
done psychedelics for
25 years because again they were super
useful for me in the beginning
then I discovered meditation on the
basis of of those experiences got really
into meditation and realized okay this
is a much more
this really is the you know conceptually
this makes much more sense to me this is
delivering the goods you know in terms
of my experience
um there's no need to keep having these
you know seeking these Peak experiences
with with drugs
but it had been you know 25 years since
I had done that and there was this
Resurgence in research on psychedelics
and I was being asked about psychedelics
and I was talking about their utility
for me but again these were Distant
Memories and so I and there was also one
type of psychedelic experience
I was I was aware that I had never had I
had never done a high dose of mushrooms
uh blindfolded you know like every every
mushroom trip I'd ever had I'd been out
in nature and interacting with you know
you know it was just been a very
transformed sensory experience of the
world and of other people
but I had never done it alone
blindfolded just purely you know
inwardly directed and at a high dosage
I'd done high doses of LSD but um
but not mushrooms
um
so I did that you know and it was very
useful and I I spoke about it on my
podcast there's actually there's I think
if you search Sam Harris mushroom trip
on YouTube you get the the 19 minute
version of that of my describing that
trip
it was incredibly useful and but what
was what was doubly useful was
my mindfulness training in the context
of that explosion of synesthesia I mean
it was it was such an overwhelmingly
strong experience
um and there were so many moments where
it could have gone one way or the other
based on my
sense of just okay
I'm going to try to resist this you know
it was like it was it was it was in
truth irresistible because it was just
so much but
um
there were moments where I was aware of
okay this is like letting go of self you
know in this context
is
is the thing that is going to you know
turn to make the difference between
heaven and hell here you know and
because there's there are experiences
that are so extreme
that you can't even tell if it's Agony
or ecstasy it's just it's just this
everything is turned up to 11 right and
it and the difference between the two is
like you know the Tipping Point is just
it's not it really is kind of a high
wire act in some sense you know you
could just fall to one side or the other
and
um yeah so what I think people want
is um
they certainly want to be able to
extract from the Psychedelic experience
wisdom that is applicable to ordinary
States Of Consciousness it's like what
is the thing you can realize
in a moment of having a conversation
with your child
that isn't distracting you from that
relationship it's not a memory of when
the world dissolved or you know when you
were indistinguishable from the sky but
it's just a way of a way of be having
free attention
and unconditional love
in this you know totally ordinary and
potentially
chaotic Human Experience you know which
can be psychologically fraught and you
can meet you know iterations of yourself
that you don't like that are that are
not equipping you to be the best
possible person in that relationship and
what we want to do is cut through all of
that and actually you know be in love
with our lives and with the people in
our lives more and more of the time yeah
and
um that's probably there's I'm not
saying that the psych you know that
repeated psychedelic Journeys aren't
can't be integral to that project
but but you know that it can't the
project can't be being high all the time
right so whatever is extractable from
that the the the occasional you know
psychedelic trip has got to be mappable
into ordinary awakened Consciousness and
the point of con the real point of
contact does kind of run through this
you know what I've been calling the
illusion of the self and again it is
that part is discoverable without any
changes in Contents right so you don't
have to suddenly feel the energy of your
body be rush out and be continuous with
the you know the ocean of energy that is
not your body right like that's an
experience that's there to be had right
there's no doubt but
this the truth is I mean just looking at
this cup
is just as formless and as mysterious as
that right when it's seen in the right
way and that's and that's that's what
you know meditation encourages you know
one to recognize
why
share the experience that MDMA
significantly altered my perception of
what's possible in terms of an emotional
stance towards self and others yeah
including animals right something that
runs very deep for me and that I had
been kind of actively suppressing an
anticipation of having me put my dog
down but also you know I'm not
um I don't know how to frame it except
to say you know my lab did animal
research for years and I was always very
conflicted about it yeah because I love
animals and yet I wanted to understand
the brain and we need to
work on animal brains and rodents or
what um yeah I'll be very direct about
this my elaborate I've worked on many
species I've worked on
um mice and rats I've worked on
um admittedly I've worked on I'd done
some cat experiments I've worked on
large non-human primates include
including macaques I no longer work on
any of those species
um I've worked on cuttlefish cephalopods
a discussion for another time brilliant
little amazing creatures maybe maybe as
smart as us or who knows
um maybe smarter and now I work on
humans because I couldn't reconcile the
challenge inside me which was my love of
animals and working on them I just
couldn't do it any longer yeah and MDMA
didn't set that transition that
transition actually had been set a lot
earlier and it was something I really
grappled with it didn't keep me up at
night but it was always in the back of
my mind right in any event I hope what
we discovered was um was worthwhile but
this is a that's a bigger debate and I
have strong feelings about this and
maybe it's a topic for another podcast
um but I'm very happy that now I work on
humans and they can tell me if they want
to be part of the experiment or not and
I trust them and I trust their answers I
think that MDMA in its role as a
pathogen I think really did set up an
understanding of what's Real and True so
think truths like that become
um they don't I felt that they didn't
hit me square in the face I just could
the feeling behind the conflict made
itself evident and what to do about it
made itself evident so I suppose MDMA
did uh did assist the transition to
purely human research as opposed to
animal research
um the other thing that I noticed it did
is that
um it made it not scary to confront
things that were scary to confront in my
conscious life and I could think about
things in my conscious life but it made
you know it brought them close in a way
that I could get closer and closer to
the flame and then some understanding
I've still
um
amazed at how answers arrive both during
the session and in the weeks and months
that follow if one puts the attention to
it I think that's why it's important to
have a guide of some sort or have some
some pseudostructure because otherwise
you can one can get attached to the
Sounds in the room and just and there's
probably meaning there but I wanted to
do some deeper work I have not had
experience with psilocybin at least not
since my youth and I don't recommend
young people do it I regret doing LSD
and psilocybin as a young person I don't
say that for politically correct reasons
or liability reasons I just think my
mind was not developed and um but I'm
intrigued by something so here's the
question
how is it that psilocybin in particular
in high-dose psilocybin and the ego
dissolution that people talk about on
psilocybin how do you think that
um lines up with some of the experiences
that you've been describing for a
adequate meditation practice because
that's something that I did not
experience on MDMA in fact if anything I
experienced for the first time what
um really feeling like a isolated
container was and the difference between
how empathy and being bounded having in
other words good boundaries and empathy
could be symbiotic I experienced that
for the first time there and I I do
think that there is learning inside of
these states that translates into
everyday life when one is not on these
states the last thing I'll say is no I
don't feel the um the impulse to go and
do 20 more MDMA sessions I think that
the three is part of this study
um were very effective for me and you
know as they say if you hear the calling
again you might do it but I'm very
curious about psilocybin in particular
and this notion of ego dissolution
because we've been talking about the
self well so so there are different ways
in which the sense of self can be
eroded or expanded or there's lots of
experiences that can still have a kind
of Center to them but be you know very
novel and and transformational
um and one can reify those as a kind of
goal state right and it's sort of the
there's a concept in Buddhism that I
think is useful it doesn't translate
well
to English or it can set up
kind of false associations in English
that that are unfortunate but so there's
a concept of emptiness in Buddhism which
um sounds again kind of gray and
dispirit in English but
it's um
uh
what it the what it's it's sort of
cognate terms are are things like
unconditioned
unconstrained open
centerless right so it's it's
um there's a
uh and and that is so when I'm talking
about non-duality when I'm talking about
the loss of a sense of subject and then
what's left in Buddhism they would often
describe what's left as emptiness but
emptiness is not a something it's not a
it it's and it's importantly it's not
the same thing as Unity right so it's
not it's not a Oneness right because
it's it's
what's what's left when the center drops
out of experience
it's not like you are suddenly merged
with the cup right it's but now granted
uh you know this is where
psilocybin and other psychedelics can
give a false impression of I think what
the goal is you can have kind seeming
merging experience you can have Unity
experiences on psychedelics which can be
quite
powerful especially with nature with
other people and with nature where you
can just feel like you know the the
energy
of your body
becomes uh incredibly Vivid and Powerful
it's just like like you're just you know
everything is just you know buzzing with
you know life energy and then when you
you know touch another person's hand or
you touch a tree
there can be this sort of continuity of
energy which can be this overwhelming
experience and again this is a a
just a 20 Megaton change in the contents
of Consciousness right it's like this is
a non-ordinary state of consciousness
but like this this is uh give some
indication of what
of how this happens
back in the day when I was uh in my 20s
and I was experimenting with with uh
this was LSD but
um some friends and I I decided we had
this brilliant idea we would we would
Camp above Muir Woods and then take some
some LSD at dawn and then walk down you
know like a mile I think from the
campsite into the into the actual proper
Grove of trees and and you know commune
with the giant redwoods the tallest
trees on Earth
um and so we dropped the acid at dawn
and we start walking but the acid came
on you know almost immediately and we
didn't get I mean we got nowhere near
the woods and we got stopped by a tree
that was just like an ordinary you know
20-foot oak tree like the most boring
tree in the world and that tree absorbed
like the next next six hours of our of
our amazing conscious attention because
it was just you know it was the tree of
life I mean it was just like could you
there could be no better tree
um so there's we're talking about
non-ordinary States Of Consciousness
wherein a emerging with life and with
with the world is possible and
that is a so I'm not saying that kind of
experience isn't possible but
there's a sort of uh expanded
self-reification it is it is a kind of
ego dissolution but there's a there's a
kind of egoity that sort of goes along
for the ride as well or can go along for
the ride and
the real insight into emptiness the real
sort of centerless you know center of
the bullseye
is a recognition that
that in some ways equalizes all
experiences and again it's it's just as
available now in these this ordinary you
know podcasting experience as it is when
you're merging Hands-On with a an oak
tree and you know on you know 400
micrograms of acid and this is you know
the this is the whole universe
um
and so it's it's it's the it's the
equality of those two experiences that
that that this concept of emptiness
captures which a com con concept of
Oneness doesn't quite capture because
Oneness is really this this peak
experience of being dragged out of your
you know your somethingness into a much
bigger somethingness right emptiness is
just no center right and then everything
is in its own place right there's still
sights and sounds and Sensations and
thoughts and feelings but there's just
there's no there's no Center and there's
no
clinging
to anything there's no cling into
identity there's no clinging to the good
stuff there's no there's no resistance
to the bad stuff there's no this is so
pleasant and unpleasant get sort of
strangely equalized and
there's this very it's it's very
expansive and it and most importantly it
doesn't block anything so yeah if for
whatever reason if your nervous system
is set up to have the oh my God I'm now
merging with the tree experience that's
that's possible from the state of no
center right and then and and on my you
know that my recent now not so recent
three years ago it was right before
covet uh but my last you know big
psychedelic experience
you know there was I was very much
experiencing that whereas you know
insofar as I you know
you know at the peak there was no me to
remember any of any of this stuff but
you know insofar as I could
experiment with
is this really different from anything
else you know there is a kind of
equalizing
to the The Emptiness recognition even in
the in the presence of a completely
transformed neurophysiology and and so
that's um again there's there's a point
of contact I mean the the the real point
of contact between psychedelics and
meditation for me is but for my
experiences on psychedelics there's I
don't think there's just no way I would
have had the free attention to be
interested in in the in the project at
all
um
and there are other aspects of the
project it's not just having this
insight into selflessness it's it's all
of the ethical ramifications of that
it's just like what kind of person do
you want to be what are your values
what's what what is a good life
altogether when you are talking about
relationships and you know political
engagement and the changes you can make
in the world or not make or it's just
you know what kind of person do you want
to be there's there's there's a much
larger consideration and I mean as you
discovered you know an experience on
MDMA can
uh
really you know both expand your model
of what is possible and what is
desirable what is normative I mean just
what kind of you know what kind of self
do you want to be in the world uh and uh
it can also help you cut through things
that are inhibiting
you you're actualizing any of those
possibilities in ordinary waking
consciousness
I've certainly found that to be the case
I mean you raise a really important
point which is that
um once these learnings take place these
understandings take place inside of
psychedelic Journeys and I do believe
they translate to neuroplasticity I do
want to highlight the point for people
oftentimes people say oh you know this
uh mushroom or this uh psychedelic
um it opens plasticity but of course
plasticity has to be directed someplace
plasticity is just a process like like
walking or anything else underlying
neural process and I I think um it's
impossible for me to understand what
compartments of my life have been
impacted by um these three MDMA sessions
but I
um in some ways I wonder whether or not
not just the transition away from animal
research but also a um
a deeper realization of the love for
Learning and sharing information uh you
know I won't go so far as to say this
podcast is happening because of that
particular session but these things
um they splay out into multiple domains
of the self and I do think that
um the key features that feel most
important to me to mention are that
um it really identified uh true loves
things that I truly love and made me
less um
less cautious about feeling how intense
those loves really are and then also
lower the inhibition point of exploring
like well what that what would that mean
right you know and one of the reasons I
bring this up and why I think it's so
important that you mention you know uh
some issues around politics and ethics
and many things have splayed out from
your Exploration with psychedelics
meditation Neuroscience philosophy you
know all the things that are you and of
course that's only a subset is that so
much of what I hear and see so much of
what I hear and see in the kind of
self-help space
contradicts itself and leads back to the
the origin without a lot of
um progress and and for instance we hear
you know absence makes the heart grow
fonder but then out of sight out of mind
you hear about radical acceptance but
then what if it's radical acceptance of
non-acceptance right I mean there are
some experiences and people for which I
radically accept the fact that I want
nothing to do with them yeah and does
that some am I supposed to transcend
that so these are the questions I think
that keep a lot of people from exploring
things like meditation
because they feel like well is the idea
to just be okay with everything is
radical acceptance just like we'll just
you know bulldoze me with within with
things even if they're you know and my
goal is to somehow
um surpass the idea that they're harmful
and I don't think that's actually the
way any of this stuff is supposed to
work although I don't claim to be the
authority on it either I you know I
think Notions of radical acceptance and
um radical honesty and and any number of
different sayings that one can find out
there are really the the most Salient
beacons and guides that most people have
in order to try and navigate tough areas
in their life including the relationship
to self but others and political
orientations and so I feel like almost
all those things can be used to anchor
down in a stance that may or may not be
informed or
to open up to ideas and so I think the
none of this can really be solved in a
single practice it sounds like but
it does seem to me based on what you've
told us today is that only through a a
deep understanding of the self as it
really is
as opposed to this illusion that you
framed up
could we actually arrive at some answers
about like what's actually right for
each and every one of us yeah I mean
there's one generic answer that I think
can be extracted both from the
psychedelics and from meditation
and just from just thinking more clearly
about the nature of of our lives and
it's it's to become more
process oriented and to and to continue
be more and more sensitive to the
The
Mirage like character of
of achieving our goals right now I'm not
I'm not against achieving goals I have a
lot of goals I've you know I'm you know
I'm very busy there are lots of things I
want to get done and and I you know I'm
as satisfied as anyone to finish a
project and but
if you look at the time course of all of
that you know fulfillment and
you you just you there's a few lessons
everyone I think has to draw one is most
of your life is spent in the process
right like the like the moment at which
the goal is you know fully conquered
that is just I mean that has a you know
it's a tiny duration and it has a very
short half-life and you're it it the
moment you you arrive at it
it begins to recede because in the
meantime you have all these other goals
that are have appeared on the horizon
you've got people asking what you're
going to do next and you you in some
sense if you're if you're focused on
goals
you really you can never arrive right
and
I think what we're what we're looking
we're all looking for in life you know
whether we're ever thinking about taking
psychedelics or or practicing something
like meditation
we're looking for good enough reasons
to let our attention
fully rest in the present right now like
so I mean that that is the logic of
success like the scent the scent like
I've got all these things I want to do
if I could just get rich enough or fit
enough or you know dial in my sleep well
enough or you know improve my life and
all these ways get the right
relationship wouldn't it be great to be
married or maybe you know I want to
start a family I want all of these these
things
why do I want these things right I want
these things because I'm telling myself
this is It's not that
all of those things are wonderful right
I'm not I'm not discounting those
relative forms of happiness or sources
of happiness
because it's all completely valid it's
completely valid to want those things
but in the Pres one thing is absolutely
clear it's possible to be miserable in
the presence of all of those things
right it's and you can add you can add
great wealth and fame and everything on
top of that it's impossible it's
possible to be absolutely miserable
having everything any anyone could
seemingly want right
you just have to open a newspaper just
to see people living out that
predicament right you know spectacularly
wealthy famous healthy successful people
who could do anything they want in their
in life apparently and yet they're doing
this thing that is completely
dysfunctional and making them you know
needlessly miserable
um I won't name names
some people come to mind at the moment
um
so
so there is a there is a a clear
dissociation between having everything
and happiness that's possible and it's
also possible to have very little you
know and almost nothing and to be quite
happy I mean you might not have met
these people but you know I have met
people who have spent
you know 10 years alone in a cave right
you know and they come out of that cave
not floridaly neurotic or psychotic they
come out of that cave beaming with
compassion and joy and I mean it's like
they've been taking MDMA for 10 years
essentially and they come out of the
cave and that now they're going to talk
about it right
um
so and I'm not necessarily recommending
that project to anyone but I'm just
saying that is that is a psychological
possibility so you have a double
dissociation here whether you can have
everything and be miserable you can have
nothing and be beaming with with
happiness
um
so what is it that we actually want in
all of our seeking to arrange the props
in our lives and our and our and the
story to have a a convincing enough
story to tell about ourselves that we're
doing the right thing
uh what are what is all of that effort
predicated on is predicated on
this desire
and this expectation that if we could
get all of this stuff in the right place
and not have anything terrifying to
worry about right everyone we love is
healthy for the moment right and we're
healthy and it's you know we've got
something to look forward to on the
weekend and there's not some there's not
a you know a Plumbing Leak in the house
that we have to immediately respond to
and we like our house and you know our
career is going fine and there's
something good to watch on Netflix and
we have all of it right
now can we just actually give up the war
right can we can we can we fully locate
our our sense of well-being in the
present moment is it can we relax the
impulse
to brood about the past or think
anxiously about the future for long
enough to discover
that all of this here is enough right
because our life our life is
we have this finite resource of I mean
we absolutely have the finite resource
of time but within this the finite
resource the Continuum of time
we have the even more precious resource
of
free attention that is that that can
find
our our
fulfillment in the present right and
because even if we're even if we're
guarding our time to do the things that
are most important to us we can spend
all of that time
we're regretting the past or you know
anxiously expecting the future and
telling it just balancing between past
and future in our thinking about
ourselves and our lives and basically
just dancing over the present and never
making contact with it right so what we
I think what we want is
is a circumstance where attention can be
located in the present in a way that's
truly fulfilling and
unless you have had some kind of radical
Insight that allows you to do that on
demand
you are in some sense hostage
to the circumstances of your life to do
it do that for you you're constantly
trying to to engineer
a state of the world that will propagate
back on a state of self that will make
the present moment good enough
and what meditation does and
psychedelics to some degree does this
but meditation
very directly does this it reverses the
causality and and lets you
actually change change State such that
you can be fulfilled before anything
happens right nothing your happiness is
no longer predicated on the next good
thing happening you can be in the
presence of the next good or bad thing
already being fulfilled and already
being at peace you know I mean there's a
there's a
I think they're misleading nouns we can
we can throw it at what is left there
but it is you know
um you know Tranquility peace freedom
lack of contraction lack of conflict I
mean like all of that is a it can be
more and more of a default
and all of that is also compatible with
deciding
you know yeah why not get in shape why
not engage this project why not you know
change your career I mean it's not it's
not that you need to be somebody who who
accepts to your point you can notice all
of these non-optimal things because no
matter how much you meditate
you know you're very very likely going
to spend a lot of your time
still lost in thought still identified
with it and still wanting still caring
about the difference between
dysfunction and and normativity in your
life right and and it's just look at the
question is what can you what can you
locate
when
the question it's really it's like how
much can you
puncture that seeking Happiness Project
with the recognition that you're already
free right that that is that's what
that's what meditation makes possible
you can keep just a thousand times a day
letting some daylight into this search
space and so it's it but it is still
compatible like you can
I mean working out is a great
um
frame in which to look at this because I
mean in working out when you're when you
when you really work out you know I'm
thinking you know mostly I mean it's
really it's anything but it's you know
resistance training or cardio or
something like Jiu Jitsu you're
intentionally putting yourself in
classically unpleasant circumstances
physiologically I mean so if you if you
were you know if you imagine what it's
like to do anything to failure right
well if you just check in and what the
on what that is like at the level of
sensation I mean that is is basically a
medic it feels like a medical emergency
right like that if you were having that
experience for some other reason like if
you woke up in the middle of the night
and felt what it feels like to be
deadlifting you know on your 10th rep on
a set where you're gonna you know you
would fail at 11 right
like that is just you know that's an
emergency but because you understand
what you're doing in the gym and you've
sought it out and like it's actually
it's actually something you like doing
right and you can you can get a real
dopamine you know hit from from doing it
um
that what you're doing when you're doing
that is your your own in a kind of a
like you're you're actually
um
transforming
a a classically negative experience into
something that's almost intrinsically
positive right certainly the net on it
is positive
um you can do that and when being able
to do that is more and more the
experience of being actually
at peace even while exerting really
intense effort in One Direction so you
can be straining and I'm sure
physiologically showing a lot of stress
I mean I'm sure the cortisol is up and
like you know you know blood pressure is
up heart rate is certainly up
um
so it's like it's it's as far as the
body is concerned is stress as far as
the eye can see but you really can be
deeply equanimous and at peace because
again because of the frame around it
because of the concepts attached to it
because you know what you're doing you
know why it's happening and you want it
um you so that that that's an attitude
you can bring into other stressful
things that take effort to accomplish
and so it's not it's not that you just
need to be a pushover
when you learn how to meditate or when
you take MDMA or you do any you we work
on yourself in any of these ways but
um
what I think you I think you want to
find is you want to find your point of
rest in the midst of of any struggle
I would say that the certainly MDMA but
and again I have less experience with
meditation and but they really I think
put us ultimately in positions of what
can only refer to as real strength he's
going to make what before seemed like
impossible decisions or even
um Concepts or emotional states to even
think about for any period of time
without deliberately distracting or
avoiding in some other way and be able
to lean into those with with open eyes
and I think that's
um to me that's my definition of
strength I don't know what other people
consider but yeah
um there's a there's definitely
something real there in each case
this may seem like a Divergence but
I and many other people are very curious
about a recent decision that you made
which was to close your account
on Twitter
um
[Music]
you still have an Instagram account I
noticed but although I never I mean my
team manages that I've never I love
friendlier over at Instagram I've been
there a lot I've never even see it seen
it so oh it's pretty good actually
imagine what would happen if you did
yeah they're doing a good job with it
um but your decision to close your
account on Twitter
um I think grabbed a lot of eyes and
ears and
um there's a lot of questions about why
it was a very large account
you know
um it correlated with a number of things
that for the outsider people might be
wondering about
um you know new leadership uh new you
know people who had been booted off
brought back on or at least invited back
on right and so on uh you are certainly
not obligated to explain your behavior
to me uh or anybody else
um for that matter but I'm curious if
you might share with us
um what the motivation was
um for taking the account down and and
how you feel in the absence of uh I mean
your thumbs presumably are are freed up
to do other things yeah I was getting
like an arthritic right thumb I think
and I think if you don't mind sharing I
think there's a there's a lot of
curiosity about you and your your
routines you've been very generous in
sharing that your knowledge
um and but also kind of like what what
makes what makes you tick what motivates
um pretty big decisions like that it
wasn't a major platform for for you
right yeah yeah it was it was the only
social media platform I've ever engaged
I mean like you said we I have an
Instagram I have a Facebook account but
I never never used those as platforms
right I'm not never on them I never
thought I've never followed people and
I've never and all the posting has just
come from it's just marketing you know
from my team
um
but Twitter was me I mean you know for
better or worse and um I began to feel
more and more for worse and it was um it
was interesting because it was very
you know I I've you know I've talked
about it a lot on my podcast about just
my my love-hate relationship with
Twitter over the years many good things
came to me from Twitter and I was you
know I was following a lot of smart
people and it had become my
news feed and my first point of contact
with with information each day and I was
really attached to it just for that
reason just as a consumer of of content
um and then it was also a place where I
was I genuinely wanted to communicate
with people and react to things and and
you know you know I would see some
article that I thought was great I would
signal boost it you know to my
the people following me on Twitter and
that was rewarding and I was I could
literally help people on Twitter like I
mean there was a there were you know
there are people who I've raised lots of
money for on Twitter just by you know
signal boosting their gofundme's and and
uh so I was engaged in a way that seemed
productive
um
but I was always worried that it was
producing needless Conflict for me and
was was giving me a signal in my life
that I was being lured into responding
to and taking seriously that was out of
proportion to its its representation of
any opinion or set of opinions that I I
should be taking seriously
so I was noticing that that um again
this evolved over years I mean this this
long before a long long
predated recent changes to Twitter
um
but I was noticing that many of the
worst things that had happened for me
professionally were first born on
Twitter I mean just like you know some
some conflict I got into with somebody
or something that I felt like I needed
to podcast about in response to on
Twitter
um
it's just so much of it it's either it's
Genesis was Twitter or it's the the
uh the further spin of it that became
truly unpleasant and dysfunctional
happened on Twitter like it was just
Twitter was part of the story when it
was got really bad and I've I've had
you know vacations that have gone
sideways just because I got on Twitter
and said something and then I had to
produce a controversy that I had to
respond to and then I had to do a
podcast about that and Bob and just and
it was just okay this is a mess right
and so at that point you know I you know
have
friends who you know also had big
Twitter platforms who would who would
say you know why are you you know why
aren't you responding to anything on
Twitter just tweet and ghost you know
just due to heaven like Joe Rogan sat me
down and tried to get you know give me a
talking to I said Bill Moore
um
and both of them engaged Twitter in that
way I mean I think they basically never
look at their ad mentions they never see
what's coming back at them they just you
know they use it effectively the way I
use or don't even use Instagram or
Facebook I mean I don't even see what's
going out there in in my name
um and so I I could essentially do that
for myself on Twitter presumably and I
did that for some periods of time but
then I would continually decide okay now
it's all balanced again maybe I can just
communicate here because it was very
tempting for me to communicate with
people because I would see somebody
you know clearly misunderstanding
something I had said on my podcast and I
think it's like why not clarify this
misunderstanding right and then and my
efforts to do that almost invariably
produced
a um
this I mean sometimes it was a kind of a
Meandering uh process of of Discovery
but often it was just kind of a stark
confrontation with what appeared to me
to be just
lunacy and malevolence on a scale that I
never encounter elsewhere in my life
like I never meet these people in life
right
um and yet
I was meeting these people by the tens
of thousands on Twitter and so it was
the thing that began to worry me about
it
and again this I understand that people
have
the opposite experience I mean depending
on what you're putting out and what
you're you know the kinds of topics
you're touching you could have just
nothing but love coming back at you on
Twitter right but
because I'm very essentially in the
center politically and because I'm you
know on my this is now on my podcast
this is not in the waking up app I'm
often criticizing the far left and
criticizing the far right
I'm basically pissing off everyone some
of the time right so and it's very
different if you're only criticizing the
left
you hate no doubt you get hate from the
left but you have all the people on the
right who just reflexively and tribally
are are expressing their solidarity for
you right and who are who are dunking on
your enemies for you and you know when
when your enemies come out of the
woodwork and if you're only criticizing
the right I'm sure you get a lot of pain
from the right but you've got the people
on the left who are tribally identified
with the left who are who are just going
to reflexively defend you if you're in
the center
criticizing the left as hard as anyone
on the right ever criticized the
criticizes the left and you're also
criticizing the right as hard as anyone
on the left criticizes the right you're
getting hate from both sides all the
time and no one is reflected reflexively
and tribally defending you because you
pissed them off last time you're like
you might be getting hate from the left
now and the people on the right agree
with you but they can't forget the thing
you said about Trump on that podcast you
know you know two podcasts ago so
they're not going to defend you and so
what I what I basically created hell for
myself on Twitter because it was um
I just you know it was just a theater of
it was just pure cacophony most of the
time and
what I was seeing was I mean like
there's no way there's this many
psychopaths in the world but I was
seeing Psychopaths everywhere I was
seeing like the most malicious
dishonesty and uh you know just goal
post moving and hypocrisy and and I mean
it was just I mean some of us trolling
and some of it's real confusion and some
of it is psychopathy but it's like it
was so dark
that um
I worried that it was actually giving me
a a very negative and sticky
uh view of
Humanity that was
I mean one it was you know I think it is
an inaccurate
but two I I I it was it was something I
was returning to so much because again I
was checking Twitter you know
at least a dozen times a day and I'm
sure there were some days where I
checked it 100 times a day I mean it was
it was again it was my main source of
information I was constantly reading
articles and and then putting my own
stuff out
um
that it became this kind of fun house
mirror in which I was looking at the the
most grotesque side of of humanity and
feeling
it you know implicated in in ways that
were important important because it was
just it was reputationally important or
seemed to be important
um I know a lot of these people it's not
these weren't just faceless trolls these
are these are people with whom I have
had relationships and in some cases
friendships who because of what
you know largely Trump and covid did to
our political landscape in the last you
know half a dozen years
um
we're beginning to act in ways that that
seemed you know starkly dishonest and
and you know crazy making to me so I was
just noticing that I was forming a view
of people who I actually have had dinner
with
that was way more negative based on
their Twitter Behavior than I think
would ever be justified by any way they
would behave in life with me you know I
mean it's like never I was never going
to have a face-to-face encounter with
any of these people that was this
malicious and dishonest and gaslighting
and weird right as as was what was
happening hourly on Twitter right and so
I just began to become more sensitive to
what this was you know just the residue
of all this in my life and how and just
how often
the worst thing that the worst thing
about me in my relationship with the
people in my life you know they're just
talking to my wife or my kids was just
the fact that I had been on Twitter at
some point in the you know previously in
the previous hour and there was some
residue of that you know if you know in
my interaction with them you know I was
like what you know what are you stressed
out about what are you annoyed about
what are you pissed off about you know
what can't you get out of your head
um what is the thing that you now feel
like you need to spend the next week of
your life focused on because it went so
sideways for you all of that was Twitter
you know a little I mean literally a
hundred percent of that was Twitter and
and so
um I just at one point it was actually
on Thanksgiving day I just looked at
this I just just I mean there was very
little thought went into it I mean
literally I mean I you know there was
more thought in involved than you you
know you know whether I wanted coffee
when you asked me when I showed up here
I mean it was just like at a certain
point I just I just saw it and I just I
just ripped the Band-Aid off and and
yeah so um and to answer your other
question it's been almost wholly
positive as you might expect given the
the Litany of of uh pain and discomfort
I just ran through but
um
I mean it's also it's it's it's
surprising to recognize how much of a
presence it was in my life
given the sense of what is now missing I
mean it's like there there's it was
there's no question there was a there's
a kind of an addictive component to it
and when you see I mean like when I look
at what elon's doing on Twitter forget
about his ownership of it and I mean I'm
not you know I've got a lot to say about
you know the choices he's making uh for
the platform but just his personal use
of it is just so obviously an expression
of I mean I don't know if addiction is
the you know clinically appropriate
um term but
you know his dysfunctional attachment to
tweet to using the platform forget it
again again forget about changing it and
owning it but just the just the degree
to which it is pointlessly disrupting
the life of one of the most productive
people in any Generation
Um
uh I that was also instructive to me
because I know Elon and I I just you
know um he's okay
from my you know of kind of a friend's
eye view of the situation is so
obviously not good for him that he's
spending this much time on Twitter
um that uh I I just brought that back to
me it's like well if it's not if this is
what it's doing to Elon and he's got all
these other things he could be doing
with his attention
how much of my use of Twitter is
actually you know a good idea and you
know optimized to my well-being and the
well-being of the people around me
um so anyway it was there was an
addictive component to it I think and so
when that got stripped off
I you know I I do notice that there's I
mean there's some there are times I pick
up my phone
and I realize this is like the old me
picking up my phone for for a reason
that no longer exists because there's
not that much I you know I you know I
have a slack Channel with my team and
I've got email obviously but
it's like that is
not much of what I was doing with my
phone really in the end and so like it's
just my phone is much less of a presence
in my life and and so it's it's almost
wholly good but
um
yeah it's you know there's I think there
is some danger in
or some some a possible danger in losing
touch with certain aspects of culture
which again I'm not even sure I mean
there's this question of you know how
much is Twitter real life and how much
is it just a mass delusion I don't know
but insofar as it actually matters what
happens on Twitter
um or insofar as I was actually getting
a news diet which I'm not going to be
able to recapitulate for myself or I'm
just not in fact going to recapitulate
for myself even if I could
um
if any of that matters I haven't
discovered that yet but it's yeah I mean
there's it was taking up an immense
amount of bandwidth and it's it's
impressive I mean I I think I said I I
you know it's like I amputated a a
phantom limb right like it was not a
real limb but it was it was a this
continuous presence in my life that um
that uh it is it's weird it actually
relates to the concept of Self in in
surprising ways because I felt
there was a part of myself that existed
on Twitter
and I you know I I just performed a
suicide of that that self rather like
that's this is ending right now and you
know there's no residue there's nothing
to go back and check there's just it's
gone I and I didn't even I didn't go
back and look at my like what's
interesting to consider is that you know
I'd been on Twitter for 12 years
I don't keep a journal I mean Twitter
what in my timeline would have been a
kind of Journal I could have gone back
to a specific hour in a specific day and
looked at what I was paying attention to
I mean that could have been an
interesting record of just who I've been
for a decade and I and probably a pretty
humbling record of who I've been for a
decade
um in terms of the kinds of things that
captivated my attention but
I didn't even you know I didn't even
think to go in the state you know
nostalgically just look at any of that
or see if any of it was worth saving or
archiving or thinking I just just
delete you know and it was um
uh and so my my actual sense of who I am
and my engagement with with
my audience my you know the the world of
people who could potentially know me
like what does it mean to be to have a
platform you know where do I exist
digitally
my sense of of all of that got truncated
in a in a way that um
is much less noisy I mean it's amazing
how much
can't get [ __ ] up now in my life like
it's like with Twitter
almost anything could happen right like
like the next tweet was always an
opportunity to massively complicate my
life there is no analogous space for me
now and you know so what I'm going to
say on your podcast what I'm going to
say on my own podcast what I'm going to
write next that's much more
um
you know uh deliberative and uh the
opportunities to take my foot out of my
mouth or to reconsider all you know
whether anything any of this is worth it
is it worth is this the hill I really
want to die on now
um it's much more um can be much more
considered and
I mean I think all of that's to the good
um but even more important than that is
there's not
I'm not getting this continuous signal
that is always inviting a response
whether on Twitter or on my own podcast
or you know anywhere else
um
and
it's just much less noisy I mean life is
much less noisy and and cluttered and
that's you know that that is it
definitely feels better right just
that's 100 better
I'm happy to hear that I know a number
of people miss you there but
um you sound happy I sense the genuine
happiness in it
um several things come to mind uh first
of all thank you for sharing your your
rationale there and how it went I think
for a lot of people I think oh you must
have like walked around in circles for
hours talking about everything it was
delete as many good decisions are
executed right yeah um you know I'm a
big fan of Cal newport's work deep work
in many ways Cals I've never met him but
um we know each other through the the
Internet space he um really ahead of his
time with this notion of deep work and
limiting distractions I think he's even
got a book about a world without email
or something like really extreme so he
had I mean he deserves some credit
because he had been
somewhat approximate cause to this he
had been on my podcast and he had
encouraged me to delete to Twitter
because I had been I had been sort of in
the in reaching some kind of
uh you know crisis point with it uh
prior to that podcast and so we've
talked about it and I had I had recorded
that podcast but hadn't released I
actually recorded the podcast the day
before I wound up deleting Twitter but I
hadn't yet released it so you know my
podcast with him you know in the intro
to it I I then give a postmortem on my
deleting it but he was he was one of the
last people who was in my head around
these issues and I I you know it was
that was not by accident I had invited
him on the podcast because I
increasingly wanted to think about you
know whether this was totally
dysfunctional well I'm a big fan of Cal
Newport today and I I am on social media
I'm on Twitter I had some you know High
friction interactions there and
um I have a process for dealing with
those I tend to avoid High friction
confrontations online but
um Instagram is a much friendlier place
by the way if you want to come over to
wear like the nice kids yeah the cool
kids actually hang out seriously I'm not
looking for a substitute okay well you
know I didn't I don't let me entice you
over there you do but I think that this
notion of of um really being able to
access what Cal calls deep work what
um Rick Rubin talks about you know um
being able to touch the source of great
creativity and focus and on a regular
basis does require
that one have certain types of and in
some cases zero interaction with certain
platforms
um that merely being on a platform and
blocking people that would just won't
provide I think a lot of energy opens up
and I'm fascinated by this concept of
energy I mean we only have so much
energy yeah neural energy to devote
um and in many ways what you described
um there's really I think striking
parallels to what I'm talking about all
along these last hours which is that
sometimes the thing that feels so
um so powerful that has such a
gravitational pull and that we think
this is experience this is life this is
just the way it is actually is an
illusion and when you step away from it
you realize that there's this whole
other dimension of interactions that
that was available all along but that we
uh for whatever reason we're intervening
in by way of our reflexive distracted
Behavior so I think there's a there's a
there's a poetry there that was a hard
case but uh yeah I got religion on this
point and it's uh that's a good change
we'll say I want to say a couple of
things first of all
um
every time you talk I learn so much and
that's you know in the dimensions of
Neuroscience even hardcore neural
circuitry type stuff which I'm you know
sort of my home
um
when you talk about philosophy or uh or
meditation or psychedelics
and even politics some a topic that I'm
you know woefully undereducated in but
um you have this amazing ability to to
blend and synergize across things and I
think today what occurs to me is that
not only is that no accident because of
your training and your the rigor and the
depth at which you've explored these
different topics but also your openness
to it but I think at least For Me Above
All is because I think you are able to
encapsulate this idea of the self and
and the different ways in which we each
and all can potentially interact with
the environment and and our inner
landscape your description of meditation
I have to say is
now has forever changed the way I think
about meditation I would no longer just
think of it as a perceptual exercise I
on the podcast I've been talking about
as something to to do for these various
benefits the benefit set of more focus
and their stress and seller of which
certainly exists but what you described
today has a um has such an Allure and a
in a um holds such a promise that
um as I mentioned I'm certainly going to
change my behavior and I know I'm
speaking on behalf of many many people
and I just want to extend my thanks for
your coming here today to teach us even
more because of course you have your
podcast and the app and the waking up
app
um and
the fact that
regardless of the political Landscapes
regardless of the what Neuroscience
feels about psychedelics or the where
things are at any point in time you
strike me as somebody who is very
committed to sharing knowledge and
thoughtful deep discourse so that people
can benefit and there are very few
people like you
um in fact there's probably only just
one and so I feel very grateful to be
sitting across the table from him for
these last hours oh nice nice well I
really enjoyed this and I want to
congratulate you on what you've built
here because your podcast is is
everywhere I I just I'm con you know I'm
a fan and
uh even more than that I'm continually
seeing the evidence of you reaching
people and and benefiting people and
it's just it's really immediate like
this is the
one of the best examples of you know New
Media just carving out of space that
that you know people didn't really know
and existed yeah you know because like
this is not television it's not radio
it's not and and all of a sudden people
have time to hear a conversation of
great length that goes into you know
nitty-gritty scientific detail on
you know hormones I mean like who would
have thought that was even possible and
so um yeah I was just congratulations
it's fantastic to see and I'm just very
happy for the opportunity to talk to you
and and your people well thank you it's
very gratifying to hear and um I feel
very blessed um in no small part because
of our conversation today thank you so
much to be continued to be continued
we'll do it again yeah and again and
again thank you for joining me today for
my discussion with Dr Sam Harris I hope
you found it to be as enlightening as I
did and be sure to check out the waking
up app that Dr Sam Harris has made free
to any huberman lab listeners for 30
days by going to wakingup.com huberman
please also check out his incredible
podcast the making sense podcast and you
can find any number of Sam Harris's
different books on meditation
Consciousness philosophy Neuroscience
politics and more you can find links to
those books by going to samharris.org if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's the best zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a five
star review if you have questions for us
us or comments or topics that you'd like
me to cover or guess you'd like me to
invite onto the huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much during today's episode but on many
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like enhancing the depth
and quality of sleep for enhancing focus
and for hormone support and many other
aspects of mental health physical health
and performance the huberman Lab podcast
is proud to announce that we are now
partnered with momentous supplements
because momentous supplements are of the
very highest quality they ship
internationally and they have single
ingredient formulations which turns out
to be important if you're going to
develop the most cost effective and
biologically effective supplementation
regimen if you'd like to access the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast you can go to live momentous
spelled ous so livemomentis.com huberman
if you're not not already following us
on social media we are huberman lab on
Instagram Twitter LinkedIn and Facebook
and all of those places I talk about
science and science related tools some
of which overlap with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
human Lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on all social media handles all
platforms Instagram Twitter Facebook and
Linkedin if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter that's a monthly newsletter
it's completely zero cost and includes
summaries of podcast episodes as well as
toolkits for things like enhancing your
sleep enhancing your focus and ability
to learn hormone support Fitness and on
and on you simply go to hubermanlab.com
go to the menu click on the menu and
scroll down to newsletter provide your
email and you can start receiving our
monthly neural network newsletter thank
you once again for joining me for
today's discussion with Dr Sam Harris
All About meditation Consciousness Free
Will psychedelics social media and much
much more and as always thank you for
your interest in science
[Music]